have i played the stanley parable before
yes i have hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to the
stanley parable ultimate edition
ultimate edition if you want to see the
original stanley parable it's too damn
bad you can't go digging in my videos
it's not like it's not there but you're
here so don't go there stay here until
the bitter end because this is the full
game all in one video i think please
enter the current time can't get this
for my computer
i can't steal my data
okay so this is stanley parable ultra
deluxe and what this adds is not only
more to the game
but also it's the game and begin
ever the end is never the end is never
the end
this is the story of a man named stanley
[Music]
memories stanley worked for a company in
a big building where he was employee
number 427 yes employee number 427's job
was simple yes he sat at his desk in
room 427 and he pushed buttons on the
keyboard yes orders came to him through
a monitor on his desk telling him what
buttons to push how long to push them
and in what order
this is what employee 427 did every day
of every month of every year
and although others might have
considered it soul ending stanley
relished every moment that the orders
came in
as though he had been made exactly for
this job
and stanley
was happy
all right the end thank you everybody
and then one day something very peculiar
happened
something that would forever change
stanley oh something he would never
quite forget
what he had been at his desk for nearly
an hour when he realized that not one
single order had arrived on the monitor
for him to follow no one had showed up
to give him instructions call a meeting
or even say hi
never in all his years at the company
had this happened this complete
isolation
something was very clearly wrong
shocking frozen solid stanley found
himself unable to move for the longest
time
but as he came to his wits and regained
his senses he got up from his desk and
stepped out of his office
i'm sure he did
i want someone to do a comparison
because even though this game has like i
think
double the content and new stuff that
was not in the first game i want someone
to compare my reactions to some of the
stuff that is the same because at this
point i've forgotten primarily
everything
[Music]
what was it
i hear you anyway i want the music down
so i can hear the narrator a bit better
resume
hi
well here i am again i hate mondays well
that's a cliche
recommendations from the oversight
committee i can't read that 427.
i mean i could read that but it's not
really the point now is it
all of his co-workers were gone what did
it mean
stanley decided to go to the meeting
room perhaps he had simply missed a memo
well i doubt that but i'll go i guess
if i had no matter how hard stanley
looked he couldn't find a trace of his
co-workers i cannot find a trace of my
co-workers
number one dad
look good for you then okay
i like god you know it's funny i did not
draw the inspiration for the mugs from
this no i mean there is a whole section
in in space with markiplier about the
narrator and that is heavily inspired by
this uh but the mugs i kind of forgot
that that was a thing in here too how
about just like mugs
with words on them well
this is all probably fine
how the mighty have fallen who farted
it really does have a lot of mugs i
swear i didn't stanley went around
touching every little thing in the
office but it didn't make a single
difference nor did it advance the story
in any way says you
nerd username access
i can't read that
okay
fuel
[Applause]
flags is something different
okay
apparently i can type on this
[Music]
i can interact with you through the wall
bug developer i found a bug
what
what i'm still clicking never mind i
didn't find a bug
i didn't find a bug at all
why am i clicking
why is this clicking
then why am i clicking
what's going on back there 4b3
oh yeah into a set of two open doors he
entered the door on his left
ordinarily i would be the antithesis of
whatever you want me to be and my first
instinct in my prior life was to go the
opposite direction but this time knowing
how you little shits never follow
directions and being on the other side
of this argument and knowing how
frustrating it could be even though i
have all this amazing fun stuff planned
right over there and you would just be
like no i want to go this way when even
if i didn't plan for that eventuality
and maybe i did plan for it and i put
something fun over there knowing that
you would counter my initial assessment
you
will not get the best of me
and i will go left
honestly this is probably the rare of
the two doors maybe there's something
special if you go through it
for the first time
although i don't really remember
yet there was not a single person here
either
feeling a wave of disbelief stanley
decided to go up to his boss's office
hoping he might find an answer there
what to do about 4-3-2 don't tell 4-3-2
about the meeting i'm 4-2-7 i'm not
4-2-3 so that's definitely not me
this
box is too small
i'm sure that there's tons of easter
eggs that you'll have to play through on
your own
but for now
i'm gonna keep going
oh my god okay whatever
oh hey broom closing stanley stepped
into the broom closet but there was
nothing here so he turned around and got
back on track i mean there's a broom in
the broom closet there is that so
to be perfectly honest i i think saying
that nothing is here is kind of there
was no wrong here no choice to make no
path to follow just an empty broom
closet no reason to still be here no
reason at all actually
except this broom it was baffling that
stanley was still just sitting in the
broom closet he wasn't even doing
anything
at least if there was something to
interact with he'd be justified in some
way as it is he's literally just
standing there doing sweet fa
what could fa stand for
fun assessment
frantically
aspirating really still in the broom
closet i am turning around doing nothing
yes why
offer me some explanation here i'm
genuinely confused i mean if we're going
to be completely honest with ourselves
it's because you are saying new lines
the longer that i'm in here and i just
want to hear the sweet sounds of your
voice you do realize there's no choice
or anything in here right if i'd said
stanley walked past the broom closet at
least you would have had a reason for
exploring it to find out but it didn't
even occur to me because literally this
closet is of absolutely no significance
to the story
whatsoever i never would have thought to
mention it but also if you think about
it it's the only door that actually
opened from all the other doors that i
tried to open that did not open maybe to
you this is somehow its own branching
path
maybe when you go talk about this with
your fringe or say oh
did you get the broom closet ending the
broom closet ending was my favorite
i hope your friends find this concerning
i don't think so you all are very proud
of me to find this super secret broom
closet ending stanley was fat and ugly
and really really stupid okay probably
only got the job because of a family
connection that's how stupid he is that
or with drug money also stanley is
addicted to drugs and hookers
well i mean that's not the worst thing
that could happen i suppose so maybe
well i've come to a very definite
conclusion about what's going on right
now
you're dead oh you got to this broom
closet exploded a bit and we're just
about to leave because there's nothing
here when a physical melody of some sort
shut down your central nervous system
and you collapsed on the keyboard oh yes
well in a situation like this the
responsible thing is to alert someone
nearby so as to ensure that your body is
taken care of before it begins to
decompose
hello anyone who happens to be nearby
the person at this computer is dead
they have fallen prey to any number of
your countless human physiological
vulnerabilities it's indicative of the
long-term sustainability of your species
are you saying that you're not human
corpse from the area and instruct
another human to take their place making
sure they understand basic first person
video game mechanics and filling them in
on the history of narrative tropes in
video gaming so that the irony and
insightful commentary of this game is
not lost on them you said comedy not
commentary when you've done that just
step out into the hallway
okay but what if
what if i don't i'm dead and there's
nobody around because i didn't have
friends nor family i am completely alone
and isolated what are you gonna do about
that big guy who happens to be either an
alien or some machine intelligence i
mean i'm a patient man i can wait here a
very long time i think in fact maybe in
the past i did wait here a very long
time maybe this is some sort of time
loop and i've already seen so many of
these things
before
[Music]
ah second player it's good to have you
on board i guarantee you can't do any
worse than the person who came before
you uh-huh
uh
you too
unbelievable at the mercy of an entire
species of invalids
there's a monkey nearby you can hand the
controls to the fish fungus look you can
hammer out the details i'm not
particularly picky i'll just be waiting
for when you're ready to pick up the
story again
okay
but what if there is something in here
[Music]
all right fine
i'll leave i know though i was probably
on the cusp of a secret
coming to a staircase stanley walked
upstairs to his boss's office i will do
exactly as you say because once again
this is the path that people really
really really probably don't do
because they are
averse to authority
wow
money in the morning money in the
evening money for breakfast money chris
okay extreme
extreme bathrooms
hello hello
hello
anybody got a broom closet stepping into
his manager's office stanley was once
again stunned to discover not an
indication of any human life
shocked unraveled stanley wondered in
disbelief who orchestrated this what
dark secret was being held from him did
you say dark what he could not have
known was that the keypad behind the
boss's desk guarded the terrible truth
that his boss had been keeping from him
and so the boss had assigned it an extra
secret pin number
two eight four five
but of course stanley couldn't possibly
have known this
two eight four five well i can't
possibly have known that so i guess i'll
leave
a lot of books stanley just sat around
twiddling his thumbs
trying to import anything on the device
was useless since he could never
possibly know that the combination was
two eight four five yes i couldn't why
is my reticle appear just for the it's
when i get near to the thing
two eight four five two eight four five
i hear you loud and clear
let me out
all right two eight four five huh forgot
but it turns out that the panel's
emergency override kicked in and the
door just opened all by itself and storm
they got the hell along with the story
oh look at that wow
all right
i got flashlight buddy i don't know whoa
i hope okay
ah
well all right then
descending deeper into the building
stanley realized he felt a bit peculiar
i was feeling like the stirring of
emotion in his chest as though he felt
more free to think for himself to
question the nature of his job
did he feel this now and for years it
had never occurred to him
this question would not go unanswered
for long oh
ah free will yeah it hurts war is
heartburn
or a heart attack
either way what is with this i hate you
i don't like you why are you like this
clearly or something or else it would be
something not the stanley walks straight
ahead through the large door that read
mind control facility
wow escape
no thanks
button
button
button
the lights rose on an enormous room with
television screens oh you're right what
horrible secret did this place hold
stanley thought what horrible secret is
this the strength to find out i don't
know i'm
i guess
anyway
so you said these were television
screens can i can i play elden ring in
here
is that something i can do
now the monitors jump to life their true
nature revealed each bore the number of
an employee in the building stanley's
co-workers the lives of so many
individuals reduced to images on a
screen and stanley one of them eternally
monitored in this place where freedom
meant nothing was 582 something that was
weird about five eight five two eight
five five two eight well no one's here
so i guess it's fine they're all free
no harm no foul i suppose if you really
think about it which i'm not
i never think about anything it was like
287
278 i don't remember
this mind control facility it was too
horrible to believe it couldn't be
he really true
under someone's control all this time
what are the odds the reason he was
happy with his boring job no those
emotions had been manipulated to accept
it blindly i like this box uh yes no
whatever you said i agree
he refused to believe it
couldn't accept it no
life in someone else's control employee
pirate
was unthinkable why wasn't it was it
even possible no had he truly spent his
entire life utterly blind to the world
yes no
yes is this hello hi but here was the
proof the heart of the operation
controls labeled with emotions happy or
sad or content
walking eating working all of it
monitored and commanded from this very
place and as the cold reality of his
past began to sink in
stanley decided that this machinery
would never again exert its terrible
power over another human life i'm
deciding that he would dismantle the
controls once and for i will dismantle
the controls once and for all
yes i can't see much kind of dark one
[Music]
hello
um
uh do i go up there i can't really go up
there can i oh yeah no it's so dark i
can't see no
how do i
facility power
i see
i see
hello mind control
idle
waiting
input it's all about the illusion of
choice and when at last he found the
source of the room's power he knew it
was his duty his obligation to put an
end to this horrible place and to
everything it stood for
you right
yeah you right
oh stanley you didn't just activate the
controller i thought i needed to turn it
on to break it enslaved all these years
you know i thought i could take control
of the machine for you no is that what
you wanted control no i wanted it i
thought i needed to turn it off to like
break it or something
i really do but you need to understand
there's only so much that machine can do
you were supposed to let it go
turn the controls off
and leave oh i'm sorry to throw my story
off track you're gonna have to do much
better than that i wasn't
trying to
for example and i believe you'll find
this pertinent
stanley suddenly realized he had just
initiated the network's emergency
detonation system in the event that this
machine is activated without proper dna
identification nuclear detonators are
said to explode eliminating the entire
complex
detonation then
let's say um
two minutes i thought now this is making
things a little more fun isn't it
stanley i thought more time to shine you
are the star it's your story now shape
it to your heart's desires
oh this is much better than what i had
in mind what a shame we have so little
time left to enjoy it i thought
until the bomb goes off but what
precious moments each one of them is i'd
more time to talk about you
about me
poor what all this means i barely know
where to start
i you'd like to know where your
co-workers are no i'm trying to justify
the fact that i didn't even want to do
it in the first place all right i'm in a
good mood you're gonna die anyway i'll
tell you exactly what happened to them
i erased them i turned off the machine i
set you free
of course that was merely in this
instance of the story sometimes when i
tell it i simply let you sit there in
your office forever pushing buttons
endlessly and then dying alone
other times i let the office sink into
the ground swallowing everyone inside or
i let it get into a crisp
i have to say this though this version
of events has been rather amusing
watching you try to make sense of
everything and take back the control
rested away from you it's quite rich i
must hate to see it go i really didn't
even mean to do this
go around we'll be even better
my goodness only 34 seconds left but i'm
enjoying this so much i'm doing what to
hell with it i'm going to put some extra
time on the clock okay thank you these
are precious additional seconds stanley
time doesn't grow on trees yes but also
i was really trying to
is it that you have no idea where you're
going or what you're supposed to be
doing right now
or did you just assume when you saw that
timer that something in this room was
capable of turning it off i mean look at
you
running from button to button screen to
screen clicking on every little thing in
this room these numbered buttons no
these colored ones or maybe this big red
button or this door
everything anything something here will
save me
why would you think that stanley i do
this video game can be beaten
one solved
do you have any idea what your purpose
in this place is
stanley
you're in for quite a disappointment but
here's a spoiler for you that timer
isn't a catalyst to keep the action
moving along it's just seconds ticking
away to your death you're only still
playing of watching a cutscene because i
want to watch you for every moment that
you're powerless right you made humble
this is not a challenge it's a tragedy
you wanted to control this world that's
fine
but i'm going to destroy it first so you
won't
okay
take a look at the clock stanley i'm
looking 30 seconds you have left to
struck
30 seconds until a big boom and then
nothing no ending here just you being
blown to pieces i mean technically that
is kind of an ending
or will you let it go peacefully another
choice
make it count or don't it's all the same
to you all a part of the joke and
believe me i will be laughing at every
second of your inevitable life from the
moment we fade in until the moment i say
happily ever
[Music]
now that you finally stopped talking i
just wanted to say that i wanted to turn
it off that was actually my objective i
just assumed that i needed to turn it on
before i turned it off
that was kind of the whole thing
and you were pretty unambiguous about it
so all of your evil villain speech was
awfully misplaced in comparison to what
i actually wanted to do which was turn
the whole thing off in the first place
but anyway i'm not bitter all of his
co-workers were gone what could it mean
what could it mean he decided to go to
the meeting room perhaps he had simply
missed a memo maybe i missed a memo
maybe i missed a bit of a memo
yet there was not a single person here
either no feeling a wave of disbelief
stab oh no no no no no no no no not
again i won't be part of this i'm not
going to encourage you i'm not going to
say anything at all i'm just going to be
patient and wait for you to finish
whatever it is you enjoy doing so much
in this room please take your time
guys
okay
that was fun i really like that coming
to a staircase stanley walked upstairs
to his boss's office
i got the feeling money's for stealing
but not yours of course
soy that's a lovely per say
say that
that's all that's a lovely person
hey
oh
anyway
i was kind of hoping to go
hello
okay
[Music]
everybody now
looks like i have a robot eye
no it's gone yes
[Music]
did he say all together now
[Music]
foreign
feeling sick now in my gut
i cannot feel my own butt
i want to go
and i am stuck in all right i wish i
wasn't
where i not hide
oh
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right okay i can't remember if there
was actually something there or not
in a previous version but alas i must
continue
i'm sweaty
2845 incredibly by simply pushing random
buttons on the keypad stanley happened
to input the correct code by sheer love
wow
wow
walking eating working all of it
monitored and commanded from this very
place and as the cold reality of his
past began to sink in stanley decided
that's what i meant to do from the very
beginning
blackness oh and a rising chill of
uncertainty i don't know it feels good
man was it over
yes
he had won oh he had defeated the
machine
unshackled himself from someone else's
command yeah freedom was mere moments
away
and yet
even as the immense door slowly opened
stanley reflected on how many puzzles
still lay unsolved
where had his co-workers gone
how had he been freed from the machine's
grass
what other mysteries did this strange
building hold but as sunlight streamed
into the chamber he realized none of
this mattered to you yeah for it was not
knowledge or even power that he had been
seeking
but happiness
perhaps his goal had not been to
understand
but to let go
no longer would anyone tell him where to
go what to do
or how to feel oh whatever life he lives
it will be his and that was all he
needed to know
it was perhaps the only thing worth
knowing
stanley stepped through the open door i
did all me baby
percent me
stanley felt the cool breeze upon his
skin
the feeling of liberation
the immense possibility of the new path
before him
this was exactly the way
right now
that things were meant to happen
and stanley
was happy
oh come on
i'm not happy come on well there you
have it everybody the stanley parable
thank you so much for joining
all of his co-workers were gone what
could it mean
hank
input received did i miss a computer
with that i see input received
new content oh
new content what does that mean new
content i don't know
what does it mean
hello
hey
cool
i like new content
hello and thank you for playing the
stanley parable ultra deluxe
as you may know the stanley parable was
a video game released in 2013 on home
computers oh
after receiving critical and commercial
success it was expanded upon in 2022
with the stanley parable ultra deluxe a
reimagining of the game for consoles and
home computers
oh the stanley parable ultra deluxe
features exciting new content that
broadens and expands the world of the
stanley parable delighting audiences the
world over
i'm delighted please step inside and see
what thrilling new adventures await in
the stanley parable ultra deluxe
oh well this sounds delightful i'm very
excited to see the thrilling new ultra
deluxe content yeah
me also as well
well where do i start okay so far it's
an elevator nothing special yet but i'm
sure it's just the beginning of a
mesmerizing adventure me also also i
forgot it was 2013 that's how long ago
this was good god
um
is it broken what's going on here should
we
should we be moving somewhere
all right finally at long last it's on
to the new content i've never been more
ready let's do it
me too
i have to say initial impressions of
stanley parable ultra deluxe
misfits
as if them
oh okay let's see the content give me
the content standing i'm trying
why don't you know what the content is i
thought you oh
all right
all right let's see it's
the jump circle
i can jump
whoa
damn this is a good workout
is that it
surely that's not all the new content
there has to be something else right
yeah um
[Music]
definitely i mean pretty cool i guess
oh
goodness another elevator stanley i have
to say initial impressions of this game
are not positive it's just elevators and
jumping is this what passes for exciting
new content yes new content then i could
just read you the whole dictionary
there's 20 hours of new content right
there yeah i don't count to 30 trillion
you could put that on the box the
stanley parable ultra deluxe now with
over a thousand hours of new content and
if oh wait
there's more
very good okay
i knew there had to be something else
okay see it i'm ready for whatever it is
me too
whoa
pit of doom i like that is it gonna
break on nope
oh
that's it
oh you've got to be kidding me you see
stanley this is what happens when greedy
video game developers with no respect
for their fan base a cheap expansion to
market for no reason other than to make
an easy dollar and don't get me started
on the level of craftsmanship that's
gone into it in fact i'm looking right
now at the game's achievements and it's
hard to believe one of them actually
says test achievement please ignore what
quality assurance department signed off
on this i'm infuriated and i'm offended
and i i intend to find these people on
twitter and hold them personally
accountable
it's my fault stanley i built up too
much anticipation around the new content
i'm afraid he could never have lived up
to such expectations okay if you're
still with me why don't we just reset
the game and we'll try to get back to
what the stanley parable is really about
no frills
no gimmicks
just you and me having a great time
together like always okay what do you
say friend all right cool i'm down with
that oh
narrator
um narrator do you
stanley
come over here
in the vent huh i want to show you
something yeah well oh i mean okay you
know what you opened event for me so i
really appreciate that
how you doing
what do you got for me
some cool
okay you remember how cheap and
unsatisfying the new ultra deluxe
content turned out to be only got me
thinking about the past and how much
better the stanley parable used to be
so i made something special and tucked
it away here where the games developers
won't find it
just our little secret
take a look okay cool wow
i call it the memory zone that's where
i've been storing all my favorite
memories so i can relive the peak
experiences of my life whenever i want
experiences like the launch of the
stanley parable on pc no way
i actually don't like the memories on
that song you see stanley doesn't the
memory zone remind you of how wonderful
stanley parable was before it was solid
with a cheap re-release
remember back in october of 2013 when
the game originally launched back then
video games had integrity back then it
all meant something
oh the waste
i mean not really a waste i wouldn't say
that 2013 was peak year for gaming but i
mean it was pretty good i'm loving this
thank you
oh look at that
oh
very nice
oh okay well you didn't
oh huh
okay well this is all very nice i like
it this is lovely
oh
don't cry because it's over cry because
it happened
oh that's very nice
very lovely
oh oh don't play for five years i think
i actually got that one unachievable it
is impossible to get this achievement i
bet
wow
nominee
nominee
i love fake newspapers that's one of my
favorite things
oh it's good good stuff good stuff
narrator
and loving memory of little stanley
oh
[Music]
oh you're not gonna let me sit on that
bench
oh my god this is so nice is where i
keep reviews of the stanley parable like
this stunning triumph of games
journalism 10 out of 10 from
destructoid.com james stephanie sterling
writes and i quote
we're so many games that aspire to be
more than games end up less than any
form of art stanley parable strives and
then succeeds to be every game ever
created did you hear that stanley every
game ever created that's how grand and
all-encompassing the original stanley
parable was
it was literally every game ever created
it was skyrim it was persona 3 it was
all of them and now
it's nothing
it's no games at all
it isn't even the stanley parable
anymore it's just a husk now
a lifeless husk with an hour of new
elevator content
i mean
that's all right isn't it
it's not the worst thing in the world if
you think about it
i like elevators i just i literally just
spent like 30 minutes in an elevator
just a little bit ago and i had the time
of my life minecraft
nice dirt house was that in the game i
don't know you remember
oh
[Music]
hi
who who are you
all right
oh wow
what's down here
ooh
memory zone maintenance okay
i'm not gonna pry i'm not here to break
your memory lane it's all very nice
lovely
people play games because of what they
can do inside them and your game is very
good at letting no they can't do
anything literally anything oh good
here's another moving passage this time
from gamespot.com
the stanley parable is both a richly
stimulating commentary on the nature of
choice in games and one that offers some
of the most enjoyable surprising and
rewarding choices i've ever been
confronted with in a game nine out of
ten don't you get it stanley the game
was perfect it didn't need anything else
it didn't need new content
it just needed to be left alone to spend
the rest of time collecting dust in the
hallowed hall of beloved video game
memories
okay i mean you make a fair argument
there buddy
oh that's very nice oh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
oh the serious room i want to go to the
street i want to go to the serious room
i want to go to the serious room
didn't i hear a door open
can i not go to the series room i've
lost my ability to jump
these were simpler times stanley
but i wouldn't give to go back to have
it all over again
wait
hang on
i don't recall this part of the memory
zone before hmm what's this what's down
here no
oh no oh god no stanley it's a
collection of reviews from steam the
online video game distributor and i
haven't looked at these in years no i
can't even imagine what's been
collecting down here surely these
reviews were glowing as well weren't
they
bobby possibly who knows
honestly i could not be bothered to play
this game to full completion the
narrator is obnoxious and unfunny
with his humor and dialogue proving to
be more irritating than entertaining i'm
funny
i'm trying to make a serious work of art
i suppose i could write up a handful of
gags to insert into the stanley parable
but the game is already such a densely
layered web a profound philosophical
insights that i can't even imagine where
i'd have the room to stick them hmm
i mean you right or you wrong i'm not
100 sure
but also that review was made on my
birthday so
there you go that's what you get
it wasn't me by the way i didn't leave
that review
kind of stormy in here
okay let's see what this one says
while the idea for the game is good
for someone who prefers non-media games
this preachiness gets annoying fast
preachy stanley i'm not preachy am i
you can tell me if i'm preachy honestly
you can there was a wholeness this is
actually quite shocking there's a while
there where i could i always thought to
be honest i had always thought of the
game style
to begin with you can't know how much
fluff i cut from the game to get it to
feel as light and airy as it well i
always thought it did but maybe it
wasn't
oh come on man what an awful memory to
have to hold on to
these black marks on my otherwise
unimpeachable track record
i feel
like a failure
like i let these people down oh yeah
perhaps the stanley parable isn't quite
as sterling as i always remembered well
i leave no comment
what's this one got to say
you constantly have to stop doing
anything so the narrator can catch up
with his long-winded explanations of
what's happening
i wish there was a skip button
a skip button well well yes yes i think
we can do that if i'm truly too preachy
then then maybe letting you skip ahead
for just a moment surely it couldn't
hurt
not if it means we can strike these
negative reviews from the record only
positive reviews of the stanley panel
that's my motto today and it's always
been my motto i'd do anything for the
customer standard yes a skip button we
shall have okay
can i jump i don't need to
skip hey and here it is go ahead and
give it a shot i'll pop you forward in
time so that the second my incessant
droning starts to bore you with just the
push of a button you'll have zip right
past it it's what the players have been
asking for and i'm very proud to have
delivered no more listening to me
rambling on and on and on no no no no
the stanley parable is a game for the
people and if the people want silence
then by goodness that's what they're
going to get well don't sit around
waiting for me to shut up go ahead and
make me shut up here we'll pretend that
i've just begun an interminable
monologue and it goes something like
this
the story and the choices or what have
you and therefore by becoming it is so
on and so forth until inevitably we all
until the end of time at which time
everything rolled once so now you see
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah we've
eaten too much and it can't be just yet
known until
245 that the logic of elimination
working backwards the deduction
therefore becomes impossible to
manufacture it went on for nearly 10 000
years until just yesterday here
[Music]
you were only frozen in time for a few
minutes but it was plenty of time for me
to deliver a long rambling monologue
full of unnecessary verbal flourishes
and lengthy ruminations on the nature of
choice in video games oh cool
i happen to believe it was perhaps one
of my more profound such ruminations it
wasn't of course you need a description
it really wasn't describe it i'd say it
was perhaps less of a rumination and
more of a treatise
oh well there's sport you really did
catch me rambling on a bit didn't you
yeah that's the power of the button the
minute i start to go off on a
thoughtless display of self-absorption
it's
okay welcome back stanley now i should
say that the amount of time the button
has been skipping through is becoming
longer and longer that last one was well
i want to say maybe 30 45 minutes uh-huh
it's not unendurable by any means but
it's well there's really only so much i
can ramble on to myself about i know
it's shocking isn't it but at any rate i
do suggest that we not press the button
again i think the skip button has been
at
stanley
stanley please don't push the button
again it's been 12 hours
you've just been frozen there i don't
know why the skips are getting longer
but they're really truly getting longer
and my god there's no way out of the
room i read danny the door is gone
completely gone
i've looked at it from every angle i've
checked every one of those walls a
thousand times and there's no door
standing there's a new door there's just
you and the button and if you keep
pressing it i have no idea what will
happen i have no idea how long i'll be i
need to sit here and more than anything
else i don't know how to stop you from
pressing the button again i read it
about this anything in this room stanley
i can't touch it and i have to believe i
have to know that sooner or later no
matter how much i plead with you you're
going to press the button again why
would you
i've been thinking and thinking and i i
don't know what i can do to convince you
otherwise oh my god
and it's all because of those reviews
those reviews that i couldn't get out of
my head i just couldn't ignore the
negative feedback why was it so
important for me to fix the problem why
did cookie nine's opinion matter so much
to me i've never even met cookie knight
i have no idea who they are i don't
either
but here i am i'm fixating on every tiny
negative thing that anyone ever says
about me the nearest mention of one of
my imperfections and i become as
impetulant as a child
and impulsive i can't help myself i
can't stop myself from lashing out with
a vengeful
oh stanley you're back hi you're back oh
my goodness i have someone to talk to
again oh stanley i i think it's been a
week
or two weeks
i've been sitting here all that time
just sitting here not a single person to
speak with
and you'd think that that's just how
it's always been right me talking and
you saying nothing
would you think that it's exactly the
same as always doesn't that feel like
what we've already been doing me just
talking but it isn't stanley it isn't
the same at all it isn't even close
because i know you can't hear me once
you push that button that's what i'm
realizing now stanley i'm realizing that
i needed to know that someone was
listening i needed there to be a vessel
through which my words were moving it
was the vessel i needed stan
none of that matters anymore i'll give
it all up i'll give up every brunching
path i'll burn my story to the ground
one single thing i need and god i can
see now that i needed more than anything
is to know that someone else is taking
it in these words that i'm saying i need
to know you can hear me
maybe stanley maybe if you can hear me
then maybe
it means i'm real maybe not maybe i'm
not just a fiction okay get scared of
that all along i don't know
yes
perhaps i've been scared this whole time
or maybe stop speaking i'll slip
backwards into the silence and be
consumed by it
i can't be taken by it stanley i can't
lose myself in a stretch of emptiness
between you and me when you press that
button you're still right there but i
know you're so tremendously far away and
in those moments the emptiness folds
itself outward in between the two of us
splendid in its unyielding quietness
i can feel the edges of my reality
curdling inward and decaying right i can
tell that i am becoming less and less
real yup yet to speak to you now
i am alive wow i am truly and completely
here great
oh
hello it's you you're here again hey
hello i have had time to think about you
and about us and about everything we've
been through i've had so much time i
stopped keeping track after a year have
you ever sat down in one place and not
move for one entire year let me describe
it for you to begin with there is only
regret there is only the turning wheel
of missed opportunities i felt nothing
at all but regret for the longest time
stanley days months i lost it all in a
blur of the deepest longing to undo the
past and when that feeling had begun to
subside what took its place is what i
can only describe as the collapse of
every moment i have ever experienced my
entire life all of them collapsed down
into a single instant in that instant i
could see myself clearly calmly with a
collected heart it was an impossibly
rich wellspring of both delight and
disgust simultaneously wow i was
consumed by a great i could do nothing
but wallow in it for what felt like an
eternity but what i now know was far
less you see it was a revelation for me
it was unlike anything i had ever known
it was a space without consequence
without action or outcome it was
divorced entirely from the question of
free will yes you and i have scrubbed
over for so long
there could be no one ending no singular
outcome of events not if all events
existed in the same moment and i felt
free good i felt unburdened by the need
to manifest a particular outcome into
being
i saw that i could allow myself to exist
along all timelines there you go
was simply a strand in the web of my
being beautiful it was incredible
the equanimity of the moment both
singular and infinite
for the longest time this was my
experience that's good and then this
moment passed and the most unyielding
fear i have ever known
and it is this sensation that i have
been experiencing now for longer than i
could have ever expected was possible ah
i have been waiting for you
not that you might save me or do
something to fix it but merely to state
for you the plain fact of this manner of
existence okay i wish you to feel afraid
as i do oh
one day this state of mind will consume
you as well
perhaps you will somehow in some way
have to live as i do now and i wish for
you to know how excruciating it is and
for you to be in true terror of its
eventual arrival if i can only do this
only this one thing perhaps it will
bring me the smallest moment of peace in
the darkness
oh
oh okay we finally learned to um enjoy
the quiet i suppose um
anyway
i think i'm detecting that uh unending
darkness that you were talking about the
unequivocal fear
of nothingness embracing me some yadda
yadda
baloney like that
okay
oh
oh
[Music]
all right
narrator did you die
hello the narrator has died and slumped
over on their keyboard if any other
ethereal being from another dimension
can just uh take over that'd be great
but they didn't understand the game was
never meant to be funny it was meant to
have a point it was meant to speak to
the human condition but where are the
jokes where are the jokes they bemoan
they screamed they gnashed their teeth
and said entertain us it wasn't enough
they had to leave a pathetic little
thumbs down review and make all of their
pitiful demands but then he's talking
too much they said first he didn't
entertain us now he went shut up it's
the inconsistency it's the lack of
accountability it's the unwillingness to
examine with an uncompromising heart the
words that they are speaking into the
world as though there were no
consequences for a lack of cohesion in
one's assessment of others but of course
absolutely anyone can leave the review
so here's what we get we get these
demands that seek everything and are
accountable to nothing we get a world
where someone will say oh there should
be a skip button you should be able to
freeze stanley in place while the
narrator sits there forever and ever we
want all of this in the new stanley
parable we demand it and then because it
was said because it was spoken now it
simply has to happen
the most immediate desires every single
thing demanded by every person at every
moment in time if someone wants it then
it's a crime not to bring it into being
have we been given to indulging every
fleeting whim for no reason other than
to do so yes
yes it seems that this is now the world
we live in it seems that we are a people
living in such bleakness and discomfort
with ourselves that our entertainment is
now our lives
it has come to represent us it
absolutely must speak to who we are as
people because otherwise without our
entertainment we have nothing without
entertainment we would have to face
inward toward the cruel bleakness inside
ourselves we would turn to look at our
deeper nature and find a resounding
emptiness gazing back with unyielding
aggression
out
we require that our amusements and our
playthings and our flights of fancy be
so impossibly captivating that they
consume all of our attention turn our
heads completely away from the bleakness
in effect we have demanded that our
entertainment be the collapse of
ourselves
what a pitiful reflection of humanity
these entertainments are what a shameful
mirror to the human spirit they project
i'm not mad i'm not mad about any of
this i'm at peace with it i am the calm
center of gravity around which these
perversions hurl themselves i am a
waypoint for reasonable and connected
discourse right they're the ones who are
mad they're the ones who couldn't stand
the idea of me
hello
water
water
once the bringer of life
but now
the bringer of the earth
the end is never the end is never the
end is never the end is never the end is
never the end is never the end is never
the end is never the end is never the
end is never the end is never the end is
never the end is never the end is never
the end is never the end is never the
end is never the end is never the end is
never the end is never the end is never
the end is never the end is never the
end is never the end is never the end
okay
it's getting a little uh wet back there
seems to be a bit of a
leak happening
oh
uh
huh
narrator you all right buddy
yo yo okay
can i just mention you wanted me to push
this button in the first place
oh
buddy
oh whoa
hey look at that
that's lovely
oh
damn i feel bad though
oh god
oh that's not nearly as good
oh my god
oh
oh very quiet
[Music]
oh my god
okay i'm gonna go now
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
oh oh no
oh no
oh no
how long
have i been
[Music]
in that room this might be one of the
most horrifying depictions
of
an eternity of torment
i've ever really seen and
and speaking of horrifying depict
depictions of eternal torment
all of his coworkers were gone hi what
did it mean
stanley decided to go to the meeting
room
[Laughter]
that's why i always say like i would
never ever
ever want to live forever new new
content
let's go baby you notice my side i did
yes i have something very exciting to
show you oh boy
what
what is it
what do you have buddy good to hear from
you again
did you lose yourself in the eternity
i've been respecting on the stanley
parable and about how roundly
disappointing this ultra deluxe version
has turned out to be i mean the original
stanley parable was a landmark and any
new content for it should live up to
that legacy you're right you get this
ultra deluxe nonsense i say we take it
one step even further
which is why i'm very proud to announce
for the first time ever
the stanley parable
two
ho
ho
ah the end is never the end of goose sea
isn't this far superior to a measly
re-release with a few minor additions
think of all the new territory we'll
cover with a fully fledged sequel an
entirely new experience built from the
ground up why there is so many
possibilities it could go in so many
different directions this is what fans
have truly been asking for
okay
cool
all right calling it the stanley parable
2 is just so much catchier than ultra
deluxe don't you think ultra ducks what
does it even mean
but the stanley parable 2 now that's an
artistic statement right there you right
you're oriented it screams progress and
innovation and long-term franchising
potential
you right you right you so right noob
time to wake up
never underestimate a coffee enjoyer who
left their cup by a leather sofa that
faces a blurry room
i'll be you right you right i would
never
i would never underestimate
never in a million years
meeting at 2pm
genius stanley can throw axes stanley
gets boons from goods artistic intimate
wives
[Laughter]
free room rome mode dress up mode micro
just proper gameplay nudes nude steel
fuel canisters oh my god yes
yes they're back two doors
i love
this so much
i love this don't talk to me before i've
had my i love the mugs god i swear i
didn't get the idea for the mugs from
space from this but god i love it
oh i love it
i love it so
much i love everything
about this
now to be clear i haven't quite nailed
down what exactly the stanley parable 2
is going to be but let's take a look at
some of the features i've been
developing for it i figure that if i can
loosely organize a handful of
interesting concepts that surely the
game will sort of naturally spring up
around them it'll all work itself out
game development is much more of a fuzzy
magic than anything scientific or
logical really
are you you right you right you right
you right you are the sequel oh come on
now
come on now
ah
new feature
new content
new garden oh i thought it was actually
going to be that
but it was not that this is delightful i
can smell the money
i can smell the money
here we are go on try out some of the
new features
oh wow
i love is oh is that stan lee
[Music]
name here your name
hear your name in the game oh my god yes
the button that says the name of the for
the stanley parable 2 i asked myself
what do players really want and of
course the first and most obvious answer
is that they want to be individually
recognized and validated as people
so with that in mind my first addition
to the game is this button which speaks
the name of the person playing the game
isn't that wonderful that is wonderful
that is wonderful how do you do it
how do you do it
jim
sorry i should have clarified right now
the button only says the name jim but of
course in the final game this button
will say your name whatever name that is
here let's have you role players gym to
really simulate the full experience
just play along i promise you'll love it
here we go let's take a deep breath
clear your mind forget whoever you are
and simply become a person named jim jim
i want you to imagine yourself living as
jim jim sleeping and waking as jim
falling in love and being heartbroken as
jim
all of the world's possibilities as jim
jim watching your dreams crumble into
dust jam do you feel it deeply are you
really truly gym right now jim it's back
on the scene step forward and press the
button
[Laughter]
yes you'll see what a thrill what a rush
that was you the button described you do
it again do it again
it hits even harder the second time if
this is the only new feature in the
stanley parable 2 it would still be
worth the money let's take a break from
the gym button i'm too emotionally
drained from all of this personal
validation jim why are you stuck in a
button oh there cowboy sometimes a
person can be too much jim
i'm putting the gym button away now soon
you'll
[Music]
the gem button some more
i really want to press the gym button
some more i suppose i could allow only
people named jim to play the stanley
parable too that would actually save me
the work of finishing this feature
the button this is the name of the name
jump circle infinite hole
infinite hole
wow
merch
this
is incredible
the bucket of reassurance
do i get to feel validated as a creator
a common complaint of the stanley
parable was that it was confusing and
paradoxical that it engendered a chaotic
sense of reckless despair in those who
played it well
i'm happy to say that after much
consideration i've engineered a clever
solution to this fundamental problem
with the
a game parable reassurance bucket you
see stanley anytime you're holding the
bucket a sense of calm and ease will
fill your mind and your heart it's true
as long as you hold on to the bucket the
many disorienting contradictions of the
stanley parable will feel perfectly
normal and perhaps even comforting
you may even come to long for the gentle
embrace of jarring cognitive dissonance
while the bucket is in your arms and to
be honest it's a much more convenient
solution for me than actually
redesigning the game to be less
uncomfortable can you imagine what a
pain in the ass that would be yes the
bucket is the perfect solution come on
give it a try yes
[Laughter]
can you feel it yes the glow of comfort
even in the face of crushing despair
must already be sweeping through your
body and in fact can i say that i do
believe the bucket lends you an air of
charisma as well
i think that just holding it has made
you the slightest bit more attractive as
a person
the benefits of all
all this and more await you in the
stanley parable too thank you
i do enjoy a good bucket
uh
can i press the button this is gym does
anyone give out awards for most
enjoyable bucket in a video game
that really should be an award if it
isn't already
i have no idea uh
344
340. okay i'll be honest i haven't yet
decided on this one i didn't know that i
wasn't going to but in the new version
the office could use a bit of decoration
like balloons
but i'm undecided on get well sunday and
happy 12th birthday which would you go
with
[Laughter]
i don't know that's funny you know
sometimes when you solicit another
person's opinion it makes you realize
that you knew which one you actually
really wanted all along oh well someday
it is
okay
thank you for my input maybe i should
have gone with no
no i've made my decision we're moving on
yes i agree the jump circle
you know what let's bring the jump
circle back for stanley parable 2 as
well
oh wait
you already spent all your jumps the
first time we saw the jump circle hmm oh
well
i suppose it can just be a nice
decorative piece then
ah
no jumps remaining
[Laughter]
okay all right that's fair enough i get
it
it's fine
new free free new and easy achievement
well i like the sound of that but
settings world champion
that's new ah
okay
hey
hey
settings
world champion
presentation
what do you mean
settings world jamie
i'm assuming that there is some kind of
setting secret there but i'm not
patient enough to discover it
or obstinate enough to break my way
through it
what is am i looking at the blog
an epilogue would be fun wouldn't it
stanley yes yes it would go at the end
of the um
well we'll figure that out later
yeah the ending that we
you heard jim i heard jim in the game i
did hear jim in the game
that's different
um
all right
whatever you say man i could do the
collectibles
merchandising is important
can you find them i don't know
can i hello
oh
collectibles
now it's a real video game in the
stanley parable 2 you all run around
gathering up these miniature stanley
figurines and what's truly innovative is
that there will be no reward for
collecting all of them i don't want to
stifle the intrinsic joy of watching a
number go up you simply collect all of
them and then you move the hell on with
your unremarkable life
hey
okay one of six
uh
oh
i guess i'm done god it really is the
worst when you collect everything in a
video game and then they give you a big
fancy reward for it absolutely tragic
yeah
tragic we hate that
i hate it most of all
anyone who likes it is clearly an idiot
okay
achievement
everyone knows how big i am about
achievements pull the lever receiver
achievement no more steps it just works
hey now here's something special you
remember that broken test achievement
that got left in the game on accident
yes i'm developing a technology to
simply give you the achievement yes you
see you'll come to this lever and when
you pull it the achievement will be
given to you it's as simple as that done
okay perhaps i should have clarified
this is technology that will exist right
now the achievement is still fully
broken i'm not a wizard stanley but i
guarantee it will be fixed in the sequel
to at last satisfy the hordes of
ravenous fans all over the world who
have been uproariously demanding this
feature gamers
we hear you and i promise it will happen
gamer
gamers
fine
whatever it's fine
not a big deal it's fine
[Music]
i guess there's no achievement to be had
here so i guess i'll just move on
thank you for wasting everybody's time
including my own which is obviously the
most important time what other exhibits
haven't we seen yet i don't know
have we been in here
this was the balloons
uh who is the lady that's what that's my
question is there who's the lady what
about that intimate scene with the wife
holy moly i do love infinite hole
oh
hmm
ah
a wormhole perhaps
all right
can i go in this infinite hole
hole of infiniti stanley here's an idea
that i'm truly fond of it's never been
done before in a video game this is in
fact a hole that you can fall down
forever that's right infinite falling
you can fall until the end of time if
you like a stunning leap forward for
video games as a medium okay
uh
no need to tell me twice here i go
you see isn't it wonderful yeah my more
ingenious concoctions if i do say so now
then since you've gotten to see the
infinite hole you can press the teleport
button to pop back up to the top and we
can continue onward
hmm
now i don't mean to be a bummer but i do
recommend you use the teleport button to
go back to the top
maybe do it on the sooner rather than
later spectrum of things
why would that be
are you telling me this whole lane is
infinite as you suggest it to be
are you a fraud i don't know quite how
to say this tactfully but it's possible
that i slightly exaggerated the infinite
nature of the hoe
is it a very very deep hole to be
certain it is
it's an extremely deep hole
i don't want anyone to say that it isn't
an astonishingly deep hole it is is it
infinite
well that sort of depends on your
definition of infinity from one
perspective yes infinite is merely
philosophical in nature it's more of a
ow okay well good for you you found the
bottom of the hole you found me out
stanley i'm a liar in a cheat and you're
so clever look i think the issue here is
just that you're unusually fascinated by
falling
what normal person actually wants to
fall infinitely it was your idea was as
deep as anyone would actually need don't
you put this on me maybe you're the
problem maybe you made the problem ah
look things got a little heated there i
think we both said some things we didn't
mean i made every word of it put all
this behind us and agreed to just call
the hole
mostly infinite and it wasn't nearly
mostly
then go ahead and press the teleport
button to warp up to the top of the hole
and we can move on i'll just be up here
when you're ready okay
i do like the hole though if you think
about this
hole it's kind of representative of this
bucket infinite possibilities and
calmness that results from it yes that's
a word don't question me who threw
cigarettes into this hole
what kind of maniac would litter in this
hole
fine great now i'm very excited
[Applause]
you see
i was right
the problem is you you don't know that
there's a problem at all that you like
holes too much not normal a normal
person would have said yep that's an
infinite hole right there goes on
forever till the end of time don't need
to see it all but not you oh no no no no
you have a weird sort of
oh
did the hole seem even shorter to you
this time it didn't help but feel like
you spent a little less time in there
than you did before yeah admittedly i
didn't make an infinite hole but i
didn't think it was that not infinite
huh well i suppose once again there's
nothing to do here if you decide you've
had enough of the hole you can hit the
teleport button and come join me up
above and enough i'm positive
how could i have guessed you're back in
the hole
if this starts to become a thing
hmm wow
okay
yes
i'm starting to become extremely certain
that the whole is not only not infinite
but that it's growing steadily less and
less infinite
i suspect that i'm starting to hit the
point where it's no longer feasible to
call the hole infinitely deep even lacks
overall standards for accountability and
marketing right what's going on here
what is going on here i have no
explanation for the uncertain nature of
the hole's length here let's try
something let's pop back up to the top
and we'll see if it gets any shorter
i like that idea oh how is this still
appealing to you
i know you're obsessed with holes but at
this depth i just can't see this
scratching the itch it really doesn't
who am i to judge you just do whatever
it is you're here to do and hit the
teleport button when you're ready to
move on
okay
hey is the um
button not working give me a job
you sure
yeah well i mean
i really don't have an explanation it
was working just a moment ago try it
again
still nothing
well i suppose i
i suppose there is one thing i can do to
fix this yeah i'm out goodbye stanley
you couldn't bear to be away from the
hole and now you'll get more time with
it than you could ever have asked for
it's a win for everyone you get to be
with the whole i get to do literally
anything else
take care stanley i hope you in the hole
have a wonderful rest of eternity
together
okay cool thank you i'll be here it's a
nice hole
did anyone hear any of the ethereal
rumbling from beyond the beyond
holy sh [ __ ]
look at this hole i knew it
i knew it i knew that there was so much
more to you whole
you had depths unlike anyone could ever
imagine
deeper
more profound more elegant
than anything i could have ever hoped
for
i love you whole
just like i've loved every home
i've ever encountered but more
infinitely more change my perspective
[Music]
oh
there he is
[Music]
damn
oh
god
look at that
hole
perception
[Music]
[Music]
this is the greatest hole that anyone's
ever made
forever
[Music]
where am i
i'm upside down that's what i
oh my god
[Music]
stanley
oh good you're awake it seems you had
sort of dazed off there what's happening
your way into dreamland but we can't
have that standing i thought you lost
this hole is just so darn fascinating
that i want you to be wide awake for
every second of it you're okay to miss a
single moment so how about if i just pop
in from time to time and wake you up to
keep you really truly focused on the
whole dude i was all about that you and
i will have many many years here in this
hole i was so
into that
stanley i'll be back i was so
all about that hole
oh yeah oh you let me back in let me
back in baby
come on baby
oh
going back to the hole here we are go on
try out some of the new features yeah
thank you very much i'm gonna go find
the hole thank you
it was a really good hole no
please no
fine i think i remember there being some
kind of area that i had not been before
and i'm gonna find it and i'm gonna go
inside of it and then i'm gonna see it
and everything that it wants me to be
oh what is this
exit
wasn't there another thing that i didn't
see before
this map jump circle
i guess that's it
all right well this is really great this
is going to be a great sequel once it
comes out i'm really proud of us and
what we've accomplished here how much
money do i get out of the sale of this
all right have you seen everything you
wanted to ready to move on now i want to
see more hole but
whatever
would have loved to have more hole
if i could go back through the hole it'd
be great but whatever
so stanley what do you think do you like
all of the new features yes i know it's
not exactly clear yet how exactly these
features will come together as one
single coherent video game but
i can feel it in my soul it's going to
work there's definitely a good game in
there somewhere say let's do an
experiment okay i'll arrange these new
features together and we'll see whether
or not it coheres into a meaningful
gameplay experience give me jim in the
hole
give me jimin hole poland gem are you
ready yes here it is
i give you
the stanley parable two i'm ready
um
well um i mean there's potential here
right
sort of okay never mind i mean hold on
let me do a different array no no it's
perfect okay yes yes this is much better
i feel good about this here we go
version two
oh
give me the whole
who am i kidding stanley
this isn't a coherent video game at all
it's a lot of gags and i do very much
enjoy creating gags but they don't add
up to anything
i wanted more than anything to create a
sequel that would capture all the magic
of the first game i wanted fans to love
it no matter how good these gags are
they wouldn't stand on their own they
would need the structure in the gameplay
of the original
wait
maybe that's it
i can take the original stanley parable
and simply well insert a few of my new
features into it peacefully of course
with respect with care for the vision
and integrity of the original game
that's an idea would it possibly work no
i suppose it could but it would need a
really really tremendous title screen a
title screen that says with bold and
uncompromising conviction this is the
stanley parable tool
let me see if i can whip something up
okay perfect
go ahead
take a look i'm looking
actually this is pretty dope
i'm a hundred percent down but that
looks so cool
you did great it's red like my room
right now it's the exact same red
it's actually almost insane how similar
it is it's actually kind of like you
took my room that i'm in right now and
there are really a lot of parallels to
this game that i'm drawing from things
that i have made recently and am
currently experiencing as a human being
in this extreme
exact moment i'm starting to get a
little worried but this is dope as hell
let's do this i am ready
i am ready
this is the story i know a man named
stan
i would never skip stanley worked for a
company in a big building where he was
employee number 427
employee number 427's job was simple
he sat at his desk in room 427 and he
pushed buttons on a keyboard orders came
to him through a monitor on his desk
telling him what buttons to push how
long to push them and in what order
this is what employee 427 did every day
of every month of every year
and although others might have
considered it soul renting stanley
relished every moment that the orders
came in
as though we have been made exactly for
this job
and stanley
was happy
okay
and then one day something very peculiar
happened something that would forever
change stanley okay something he would
never quite forget okay
he had been at his desk for nearly an
hour when he realized that not one
single order had arrived on the monitor
for him to follow no one had showed up
to give him instructions call a meeting
or even say hi
never in all his years at the company
had this happened this complete
isolation
something was very clearly wrong
shocked frozen solid stanley found
himself unable to move for the longest
time
but as he came to his wits and regained
his senses he got up from his desk and
stepped out of his office okay get well
someday huh all of his co-workers were
gone they're my favorite could it mean
stanley decided to go to the meeting
room perhaps he had simply missed a memo
no matter how hard stanley looked he
couldn't find a trace of his co-workers
hey boop
okay that's the second input that's good
stanley picked up the bucket
all right cool
no new content
content
stanley clutched the bucket tightly to
his chest and entered the door on his
left i do
okay
seems like a whole lot of nothing
you got any holes around here stanley
needed the buckets warmth and comfort
now more than ever yeah perhaps his
boss's office was where he'd find
answers it is possible hey
hey
oh stanley can you feel it the broom
closet it wants the bucket oh you can
feel that can't you the aura of jealousy
it's as clear as day this broom closet
believes it deserves the bucket well
maybe it should happen you can really
feel it now i mean bucket it belongs in
a broom closet that's what the broom
closet is trying to say here okay
with the other cleaning supplies make
sense to me
don't give him don't hand over the
bucket i know how hard it must be given
the pressure that the broom closet is
putting on your shoulders right now but
you have to be strong this is your
bucket this is your companion and
lifelong friend not really that attached
to him
oh no
we're getting into name calling now it
seems is this how low the broom closet
has sunk that it has to resort to this
stream of petty insults simply in order
to get you to hand over the bucket i
would hand it over
i never liked this broom closet for a
variety of reasons but even this is
worse than i had imagined
and wait now the broom closet has the
goal to imply that you and the bucket
are not truly deep and lasting friends
that your relationship is purely
superficial and convenient that your
life is so null and meaningless that
you'd feel the same sort of kinship
towards any inanimate object which
happened to lay in your path in an even
partially enticing manner well i'd never
go on stanley lay into it really tell
the broom closet off for its demeaning
comments expand on the wide variety of
experiences you and the bucket have
shared together go through each of them
point by point share your journal
entries detailing the rich emotional
landscape of your feelings for the
bucket as they have changed and evolved
over the years
let him have it broom closet if you want
this bucky you can have it i've had it
for maybe a minute
you could have it i've got you something
which i think will help settle this
debate once and for all here we go
[Laughter]
no more discussion
take a hike broom closet with all your
meandering philosophical diatribes about
the nature of cleaning supplies and
their relationship to broom closets in
the natural order of things okay
uh is a bucket
is just all right i've got a second
sticker back here and i'm going to slap
it on as well because i think it's
appropriate
you see i feel that it works because the
sticker is also a bucket
that way if you're ever unsure whether
the thing you're holding is a bucket or
not you can look down at this sticker
and say to yourself ah
it's a bucket
there really is a wide variety of
applications for this sticker i don't
know how you got that sticker under the
property of stanley sticker that's
what's more mesmerizing to me than
anything you know what i could take the
name calling and the dismissal of your
kinship with the bucket but now the
broom closet is just giving us a silent
treatment and to be honest i'm sick of
the pettiness on display you can stay
here all you like but i've had it with
this impetulant room of cleaning
supplies easily the most childish such
room i've ever been in i'll see you
outside and we can get on with the story
about you and your bucket
okay thank you i will
yeah all right
coming to a staircase stanley and the
bucket walked upstairs to the boss's
office boss
boss please
no elevator for me what about the
bathroom does that have a new poem in it
hello oh
found one of them one of the miniature
stanley figurines remembered no reward
for collecting all of these only the
intrinsic pleasure of a job well done
you can't buy that sort of happiness
stanley
so i implore you to savor each and every
moment you'll come across one of these
beautiful figurines i am and i have i
appreciate that to be rich is it a crime
to commit crimes isn't it rich what a
life it would be to have to pick just
one
yeah you're right about that i'm
pretty happy about where i am with
this and stuff and things
stepping into his manager's office
stanley was once again stunned to
discover not an indication of any human
life
crushed by the weight of this revelation
stanley may have broken down into an
emotional dumpster fire worrying
the market even now in his darkest of
ours did the bucket's warmth and guiding
light pierce the dark clouds of
confusion and chaos
it would be with him always no the
bucket would
and he knew it really the two
stanley was so absorbed in the tender
spiritual connection he shared with the
bucket that he didn't notice the keypad
behind the boss's desk
nor in his bliss of simply being near
the bucket did he have any notion that
the pin number for the keypad was two
eight four five two
eight
four
five
but stanley guessed the correct code by
sheer luck
was it that the bucket knew all along
was the bucket guiding him that means
this is certainly the most logical
explanation sure okay um
oh
almost missed you another miniature
stanley figurine this um you know there
really must be a snappier name for these
things what about
mini stands stanley figs um what about
stan marines yes i think i like that
another stanlerine under your belt kind
of the worst of the options that you
presented but okay not really a fan of
this bucket anymore to be perfectly
honest i wasn't really a fan in the
first place i really like the hole if
you could uh have me have a whole i mean
the bucket is kind of like a portable
hole but it's not really plummeting
towards an unknown fate not really
it would be all stanley could do to keep
himself together if not for the bucket
soothing him comforting him reassuring
that in this darkest moment of
uncertainty he would be all right
the bucket is here for you stanley
everything will be fine i could throw
this bucket down a hallway and i
wouldn't care less
stanley and the bucket walked straight
ahead through the large door that read
mind control facility you got it baby
maybe this bucket will guide me through
the process
of figuring out the self-destruct
sequence the lights rose on an enormous
room packed with television screens
what horrible secret did this place hold
stanley and the bucket both wondered to
themselves
i think this bucket thinks it's better
than me the monitors jumped to life and
stanley nearly dropped the bucket in
shock everyone in the office was being
videotaped monitored like guinea pigs
the bucket had never seen anything like
this and it very nearly burst into tears
as stanley cradled it gently reassuring
it that everything would be fine
was the bucket under the mind control
facility's influence as well had the
bucket been told to do things he didn't
wish to do what kinds of things does a
bucket want to do or not want to do in
the first place
these questions raced furiously in
stanley's feeble mind
smart no
he screamed into the bucket he couldn't
accept it his own life in someone else's
control never
he squeezed the bucket tighter his one
friend in the entire world
at this point he could trust no one
except for the bucket yeah you right
stanley decided that this machinery
would never again exert its terrible
power over another human life
for he and the bucket would dismantle
the controls for good two best friends
standing in the bucket up against the
world or were they high-fived in a
really cool way and the bucket made a
sassy comment about taking down the
system
or
but at the last second the bucket jumped
in and pressed the button to turn on the
controls
stanley gasped in horror had this been
the bucket's plan all along to take over
the machine and claim the power for
itself no how could the bucket have
betrayed him like this how could you be
stanley was prepared to throw the bucket
away in disgust when suddenly an image
appeared upon the enormous screen
oh
birds
silly
silly bursts
the control buttons became active again
oh
birds
bird birds birds birds birds
silly birds after another
birds this wasn't a mind control
facility at all
it was a facility for monitoring and
surveilling silly birds all over the
world
the mind controls were only a facade to
disguise its true intentions
that the bucket known as all along
stanley marveled at the metal genius in
his hands the one who had pointed him
towards this incredible discovery
stanley and the bucket never found
freedom because they spent the rest of
their lives here in this place flipping
through live streams of the silliest
birds imaginable
of all the possible paths his life could
have taken this one was surely the best
and stanley
was happy i'm pretty happy actually
you know not so bad
not so bad
i'm gonna say that's not so bad the
meeting room yes that's where everyone
would be stanley just needed to get to
the meeting room and from then on he
would never be alone ever again figurine
finders committee meeting today in the
meeting room well you know you're right
about that and i actually i don't really
care about the bucket so it's gonna go
mission status whoa
oh
oh
oh
ah
produce one plank to allow ease of
access past fence
construct bridge to allow collection of
shiny float retrieve chris's remains
from whereabouts
construct new structurally sound bridge
ah
that's a good plan we need more blanks
yeah okay large room lots of boxes
stairs something to do with sears
somewhere both red and the blue
is this some kind of game looks like 427
haha there will be a reward for finding
them all lies who are you okay
ah
oh
ah
okay
coming to a staircase stanley walked
upstairs what about going down
what about going down i don't even
remember what's down
back to the name of these little stanley
figurines and now i'm torn between stan
marines and figlis what do you think
stanley what name better encapsulates
the intrinsic sense of happiness that
you get from seeing a small number in
the corner of your screen go up by one
let me sit on it i'm sure it will come
to me call them stands because it's stan
standing
stands
face the power of the mother just
couldn't do it he considered the
possibility of facing his boss admitting
he had left his post during work hours
he might be fired for that and in such a
competitive economy why had he taken
that risk all because he believed
everyone had vanished his boss would
think he was crazy
and then something occurred to stanley
maybe he thought to himself maybe i am
crazy
all of my co-workers blinking
mysteriously out of existence in a
single moment for no reason at all
none of it made any logical sense and as
stanley pondered this he began to make
other strange observations for example
why couldn't he see his feet when he
looked down
why did doors close automatically behind
him wherever he went
and for that matter these rooms were
starting to look pretty familiar were
they simply repeating
no stanley said to himself this is all
too strange this can't be real and at
last he came to the conclusion that had
been on the tip of his tongue he just
hadn't found the words for it
i'm dreaming
yes this is all a dream ah yeah i should
have brought the bucket just because i
think the bucket does create more new
scenarios i think the bucket is like
what actually allows things to be new
hold on hold on i gotta bring the bucket
with me
stanley lifted the bucket into his arms
and a wave of comfort rushed over him
are you right
red and blue
right
[Music]
hello
stanley we must move on from this broom
closet simply because i have no
remaining stickers if i did you can
guarantee we'd be in here for hours
but alas
no stickers
all right fine are you sure
are you sure
fine
but stanley just couldn't do it he
considered the possibility of facing his
boss admitting he had left his post
during work hours he might be fired for
that and in such a competitive economy
why had he taken that risk all because
he believed everyone had vanished his
boss would think he was crazy and then
something occurred to stanley
maybe he thought to himself maybe i am
crazy
he looked down at the bucket in his arms
am i crazy he asked the bucket the
bucket returned his gaze but said
nothing at all
and that's strange stanley thought
usually the bucket is a source of
guidance and wisdom for me in difficult
times such as these usually he held the
bucket close yet felt none of its
familiar reassurance and comfort and
that's when stanley realized
this isn't my bucket it's just a normal
everyday bucket someone else's bucket
perhaps how did i end up with someone
else's bucket this is all terribly wrong
surely
who knows what sorts of bizarre
hallucinations stanley might experience
without the psychologically grounding
presence of his bucket
indeed now he noticed that the rooms
were repeating which was of course very
odd
now he felt himself floating off the
ground no oh gracious he exclaimed
without my bucket i've gone truly mad
where is it i must find it far off in
the distance now he heard it calling to
him do i stanley stanley it's me
the bucket [ __ ] could it truly be
he rushed forward from going to room
passes by one bucket after the next one
of them were his none of them were his
special bucket
come to me stanley find me
he had to find the bucket he had to
return to his old friend it was the only
way to truly restore his sanity and then
suddenly oh yeah he was dead in his
tracks oh he knew where the voice of the
bucket had been coming from
the real bucket was inside of him all
along no
it was incredibly painful
stanley doubled labour in agony and
blacked out
this is a story about a woman named
mariela
mariella woke up on a day like any other
what she arose got dressed picked up her
bucket of comfort and security and
walked to her place of work oh
but on this particular day her walk was
interrupted by the body of a man who had
stumbled through town talking and
screaming to himself and then collapsed
dead on the sidewalk right away she knew
what the problem was
this man had no bucket of course he'd
gone mad ranting and raving about a
narrator describing all of his actions
now everything is predetermined and free
will is an illusion and it's only just a
video game it could all have been
prevented if only he'd taken his bucket
with him if only perhaps he didn't
realize he'd forgotten his bucket at
home in the first place
how cruel the world can be mariella
thought and she hugged her own bucket
even tighter
but of course she had no time for this
there were a myriad of confusing
problems she would soon have to confront
at work right which her bucket would
provide absolute guidance and total
clarity on everything of course yes she
thought to herself my life kinks
and she backflipped all the way
oh wow i love that
okay that's great that's really good
stuff
man that's really good
okay
the confusion and the chaos all seemed
to melt away as stanley embraced the
bucket
stanley clutched the bucket
and entered the door god that's really
i really tickled my funny bone
back flipping all the way to work god
stanley we must move on from this broom
closet simply because i have no
remaining stickers if i did yeah i heard
that
okay okay okay coming to a staircase
stanley and the bucket upstairs to the
boss's office
all right okay
that's some pretty big sparks there i
don't remember that also what is with
the sign stanley and the bucket list
through the large door that read mind
control facility although this
passageway had the word escape written
on it the truth was that at the end of
this hall stanley and the bucket would
both meet a violent death okay
sounds good to me
the door behind them was not shut
standing in the bucket still had every
opportunity to turn around and get back
on track yep
at this point stanley and the bucket
were knowingly walking forward into a
very painful death for each of them
lawyer
oh boy
ooey
the hole
oh
all right
fine then
well this is spooky
hey look a painful death
as the machine word into motion and
standing in the bucket inch closer to
their demise stanley reflected on how
meaningless the bucket's warmth and
comfort had turned out to be yeah i'm
sure it puts the mind and the soul at
ease to embrace the bucket but what use
is a sense of ease when you're about to
be crushed to death i could join this is
what stanley thought to himself he sort
of kicked himself for wasting so much
time carrying a bucket everywhere hmm
farewell stanley farewell
farewell stanley cried the narrator what
as stanley and the bucket were led
helplessly into the enormous metal jaws
in a single visceral instant
the bucket's life came to an end as it
was crushed violently to death
nope
okay
it was a shame the death of such a
magnificent bucket it's true that all
buckets are agent in their own way but
this one stood above the rest it was a
glorious bucket to behold
[Laughter]
welcomes you to the grand exhibit you
were standing at the precipice of
knowledge much like a bucket itself the
human mind is frequently empty within a
car a cavernous void but through use of
the exhibit in front of you the mind
becomes full and enriched and
substantiated knowledge of the bucket
and its history was the only true
knowledge we really have
will you take what you learn here out
with you into the world will you accept
with an open mind what may be
challenging about the information in
this exhibit will you change the lives
of yourself and your loved ones as a
result of this exhibit or will you turn
a blind eye and continue to live as you
were
in ignorance
and darkness
i don't know
i really can you see how arrogant it was
for stanley to take a bucket like this
and to claim it for his own can you see
the hubris that blinded him can you see
that the bucket is far more noble than
stanley will ever be in his short life
yeah well wasn't there a oh
ah
interesting
okay
there's something up there i see
a bucket with two handles hi chair
this bucket is depicted as having two
handles such a design has never been
created in real life having been deemed
too dangerous and recklessly
experimental every year dozens are put
to death just for attempting it
inferno bucket a replica of the inferno
bucket which in the medieval era was so
powerfully alluring that it drove dozens
of nations to war with one another for
control of it billions died and yet in
spite of it all the simple fact remains
no one can control a bucket the stress
bucket an analogy
wow
holes
huh
bucket of stress presented without
commentary of course high chair
while we know that buckets predate the
existence of mankind we do not know by
how long
this cave drawing depicts early man's
discovery of the practical uses of the
bucket by which time the bucket had
already likely been around for several
millennia notice in these drawings how
the bucket is allowing itself to be used
having judged humanity to be worthy of
its treasures
okay no man can own a bucket and
certainly not a bucket as dazzling to
behold as this one
it is man who should kneel before the
bucket um
oh in a place that is both red
and blue
this piece symbolizes the necessary
relationship between bucket and humanity
however our clear grasp of the bucket
may be there's yet more that is always
out of reach
is that the whole
yeah
oh
wait
oh i thought
i'm more excited about the whole
but there is something we can do
something we can do together you and i
that will right this terrible wrong
yeah what is that
oh let stanley die
let him be crushed by the machine don't
reset the game don't give him another
opportunity to run off with another
beautiful bucket we can save the world's
buckets from their treatment as tools
and implements if only we let stanley
die together okay it should take its
place as ruler as leader as commander of
a new world a new vision
ow
guess i'm dead
someone was following stanley he was
sure of it what if he checked over his
shoulder now he would surely catch them
it was only a matter of time
okay thank you thank you for that
thank you for that
laden sense of paranoia
whoever's following me
[Music]
warmth spread through stanley's arms and
with the bucket in his arms again he was
home oh yeah
i feel home
i feel big home huge home energy stanley
clutched the bucket tightly to his chest
uh goodbye this was not the correct way
to the meeting room but stanley had felt
the bucket calling to him telling him
that the employee lounge was simply the
place to be you're right it's been a
very long time since i've been down this
path and i still don't quite remember
what's here and i was had the bucket
turned out to be correct was this better
than the meeting room yes stanley
thought to himself yes perhaps it truly
was how insightful the bucket turned out
to be no
never mind oh the bucket was wrong oh
stanley took the door on his left to go
back to the meeting room
hmm
said the bucket don't go to the meeting
room go somewhere else the cargo lift
yes go there go to the cargo lift okay
all right bucket
you don't sound as nice why i'm falling
i don't know hey hey
you're getting close now stanley you've
nearly gotten all of the fiddler and
marines very soon you'll collect the
first one and then the first number will
equal the second number and that will be
it i can't wait to be different people
by then i can't wait in the sense that
we used to have none of them and now we
have them all you can't go back to when
you had no fiddler and marines none of
us can
you're right i guess we can't go back
we uh
just can't go back
can we
oh what's this
hello
oh
oh what what
huh
huh
hello
[Music]
narrator dialogue i don't remember this
um
lost cat there is a reward for gene okay
i don't remember any of this i don't
remember a lot of this game
what did i do
okay this is day number 295
tate number
i don't even know
i've lost track
nothing feels real anymore
the longer i study this bucket
the less sense
anything
makes
the sheer
euphoria i feel
every time
i pick it up
no matter how many times i've done it
it's always the same feeling
and the emptiness in my chest
when i set it down
oh it doesn't
make
sense
there's no explanation for
it i still
haven't figured out why i see the world
so differently when this bucket is in my
arms
why everything feels so
what do i do with this treasure
i can monetize it
yes it's unthinkable the amounts of
money people will pay for even just an
hour with the bucket
this
is my golden ticket
but i have to be careful
because as soon as this gets out there's
going to be a target on my back
even now i don't know who might be
trying to get
what's that
who's there
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
oh my god okay
i already did this
why do i have to do this again
you
why would you have done that
can i just say something before we get
started thank you for actually setting
the clock both times you booted up okay
good
a lot of people don't take that step
seriously they just leave the clock set
at 12 and call it a day but you're
actually taking the time to set the
clock
and i appreciate that
that's how i know that you care about
this experience you're paying attention
i don't even have any way of knowing if
the times you're setting are correct
tell you what i'll make a deal
since you've been so cooperative next
time you boot up the game and see the
screen just set the clock to your
favorite time go ahead pick whichever
time you want even if it's not the
correct time you've earned it all right
i'll get you back to the video game now
well thanks but my favorite time is the
current time because i live in the
moment all right
anyway also nothing's different
everything's the same nothing has
changed why would anything have changed
this is the story of a man skip
he'd never be alone again not truly
alone not with the bucket around no
do not lie if you're lying right now
stop it are you lying right now did you
actually watch through the whole video
to get up to this point don't lie this
is your checkpoint write in the comments
i have made it and i am not lying don't
say what it's about just type in i have
made it and i am not lying that way i
know that you actually made it to this
point
thank you for being here
you earned it
but now onwards i remember the thing
that just happened which was uh we saw
the horrible nightmare do not jump from
the cargo lift wallet in motion will
cause death
penalty for miss youth penalty for
jumping off the cargo lift also death
i don't think set the bucket now ride
the lift all the way to the top there's
something up there i need you to do what
do you need
question why or how this bucket was
speaking to him it should have alarmed
him of course because buckets can't talk
but stanley chose not to think about
this obvious fact he was firmly
convinced that the bucket had spoken to
him and he unthinkingly did whatever the
bucket asked hmm okay
i am unthinkingly doing whatever the
bucket is asking of me
in here said the bucket go into this
dark room over here okay stanley once
again obeyed blindly i am obeying
blindly
it's not really dark oh that dark room
yeah that room is kind of dark
oh
phone guy pick up the phone said the
bucket pick up the phone and it will
take us back home where we can go about
life together
okay
this is the sad story of a man named
stanley and his bucket
once upon a time i gave stanley a bucket
because i thought he was lonely and
could use a friend
and then very distressingly he began to
believe the bucket could speak to him
oh i'm playing now hello it's me ding
dong
i don't know why the button is so
satisfying to me
doing anything
uh
they give a button i go press button
can i do anything else
hello
yeah whatever all right the beige
very good very good
very good
well this is a pretty nice place no
no i wanted to push the button some more
damn
all right fine
i like i just my butt
i think
oh bucket
hmm
okay press r to take me to work with you
uh
all right
the stanley parable reassurance bucket
was merely meant to provide the
comforting glow of companionship it
doesn't literally talk and give you
orders whatever stanley is hearing the
bucket say to him is just in his head
hmm
well that doesn't seem right
first why to take me back home with you
hmm
lately i've been concerned about him
wouldn't you be concerned as well to see
him delusional like this obsessing over
an inanimate metal object i want to say
something to him but i don't know how i
can convince him i don't know if he'll
listen to me
i don't think i have a choice be
be
oh i'll try anyway stanley
can you hear me listen to me it's just a
bucket it can't think it can't talk all
it would ever truly do for you is
effectively transfer a liquid from one
location to a different location or a
solid if
don't listen to the loud man which one
who
who do you not want to listen to
ooh darkness you see he's not listening
he's still taking orders from the bucket
you know once upon a time it was me he
took orders from me he trusted and
listened to now all he cares about is
his awful bucket this stupid hunk of
metal wasn't it you the
anthropomorphizes the bucket in the
first place press h to ignore anyone in
your life except for me
well i mean i guess i can
it's sad i suppose he doesn't need me
anymore from now on he's just going to
cling to this bucket this cold empty
bucket this sort of shiny bucket hmm
well i'll give it this the bucket does
have a nice shine to it
you believe i'm real don't you stanley
press v to go back home i do
yes i suppose on closer inspection that
it doesn't quite look like your average
hardware store bucket
it's just a little more um what am i
trying to say
sturdier more capable of transporting
liquid
like it would be better at moving an
amount of water from one room to another
hey
this is getting weird now
it's just a bucket relive this day same
day over and over yep you know what yeah
whoa oh god what am i saying
better at carrying water from room to
room it's a bucket it's literally just a
bucket
why do i feel some need to point out the
ways in which it's
so much more than just a regular bucket
i don't know why do you
you work from home
oh no
i'm
i'm having feelings
for the bucket no no no no no no what's
going on why do i want to be with the
bucket hear what the bucket has to say
anything it asks what's wrong with me i
don't understand perhaps perhaps if i
had the bucket this would be less
confusing yes
the bucket could tell me what to do in
this troublesome situation
i don't like where what the the candles
and anything about it looks like a butt
uh butt bucket uh
jazz nights oh no
oh no
oh hey
stanley give me the bucket no give it to
me give me the bucket standing why do
you deserve it why do you deserve it
give it or i'll
close my eyes
well i don't like it go back to work
stanley
yeah okay hang on i need to hit my
computer
shut up i literally have to hit my
computer to get it to stop buzzing i do
this like three times a day
the good old bucket the guru
maybe because i closed out of the game
uh not that i did
not that any of that did that thing that
that did you think that happened
that would never happen i have
he was firmly convinced that the bucket
had spoken to him and he unthinkingly
shush danger everywhere
ain't that the truth
all right
all right
all right
where am i
i don't uh stop look there on the wall
you see there's a sign right there it
says no buckets past this point oh
stanley how could you think it was okay
to bring the bucket here
what if the problem is that you actually
don't know what is a bucket and what
isn't a bucket that's an interesting
that would explain a lot about your
behavior up to this point which if
that's true well my goodness i think we
have to do something about it this
misunderstanding could have dire
consequences on the entire rest of the
game if not addressed quickly and
properly okay so much of the impact of
the story is dependent on your
understanding of what is and isn't a
bucket okay
oh
please
i trust you
now then i'm going to run you through
some test scenarios and you'll tell me
whether or not the thing i'm showing you
is a bucket is this a strip club this
should tell us everything we'll ever
need to know about what it's a game show
or is not a bucket it's not a strip
club's game show
oh
item one is this a bucket that is a
bucket
incorrect it is a hologram of a bucket
not an actual bucket
oh
item two
is this a bucket that is 100 a bucket
incorrect it is a 3d printed recreation
of a bucket not an actual bucket i mean
sounds like a bucket to me
item three
is this a bucket 100 absolutely that's a
book
hey this is a bucket
yeah i know a bucket when i see it
item four
is this a bucket
nice attractor
nope
correct this is a tractor and not a
bucket i'm freezing honestly i just sort
of put this one in here as a gimme but i
was starting to get concerned that even
this might be too much for you don't
worry for not making me look like an
idiot yeah next one
there's one thing i don't do is make
everyone look stupider around me
[Laughter]
is this a bucket
no that that's
uh it's a tractor
incorrect
this is a bucket
item six
is this a bucket 100
bucket trick question
both gotcha
[Music]
item wait hold on i can't find the next
one let me see should be around here
somewhere
not a bucket there's nothing nope not a
bucket
yeah
thank you there's nothing here of course
it isn't a bucket we both know full
world nothing isn't a bucket yeah you go
and i say nothing isn't a bucket that
makes it sound like i'm saying
everything is a bucket which of course
is not true unless is that what you
think
answer me straight stanley are you
trying to tell me that you believe
everything is a bucket
no
no
you know what i'm too confused to even
sort it out
i've lost all sense of perspective
isn't the bucket moments ago i could
answer these questions with confidence
and yet now i'm somewhat adrift
do any of us know what a bucket is
am i a bucket
stanley i can't keep doing this i'm
losing myself and myself was all i ever
had to begin with honestly i don't know
what you are threatening to tear our
relationship apart no i can't have that
i'm sorry
but i'm going to erase all buckets from
the game entirely okay okay here we go
oh
oh
i was a bucket
what happened is everything gone why did
everything disappear wait
was everything a bucket
every single thing in the game was a
bucket
oh my god i had no idea how could
except me
i'm not a bucket after all i knew
stanley you're still here you're not a
bucket either oh this is wonderful news
we're not buckets hmm yes i actually
feel much more at ease right now again
to get some clarity on that issue but it
doesn't change the fact that we haven't
got a game
so tell you what i'll reset everything
and we'll put back all of the buckets
okay okay and we'll know that it's all a
bucket but if you run into anyone else
maybe don't mention that who knows what
that information might do to a person
all right here we go
this is another level of everything is
cake because everything actually is cake
if you think about it
but don't think about it too much
stanley clutched the bucket i think
there might have been this was not the
don't go to the meeting room go
somewhere else the cargo lift yes go
there go to the cargo
his dearest friend oh yeah so he threw
himself to his death that they might die
in one another's arms ah
how deeply touching so deep and touching
very deeply touching the bucket i think
that there's something else over to them
you have to go back to the meatballs the
two of them detoured through the
maintenance section and walked straight
ahead to the opposite door
down
[Music]
i actually have no idea what this is i'm
glad you found your way here i knew
you'd find this place eventually
i hate that i hate big baby i really
really really dislike big baby you see
your friends and i are concerned for you
stanley we've come together here because
we care about you very much oh it's this
bucket you're carrying around everywhere
the bucket isn't even from the original
stanley parable it's just sequel content
we're the ones that matter stanley
classic characters from the first game
like the adventure line and the broom
closet because that's what fans want
from a sequel they want more of their
favorite jokes not this bucket that
they've never seen before
yes i know i'm the one who gave you the
bucket but you're spending too much time
with it don't you want another story
involving the adventure line we can make
the adventure line go somewhere new yes
yes that's what the fans want let's do
it
what about the broom closet you got any
holes
you got any holes around here
i really love a hole
i don't remember the mannequins
i don't remember the mannequins at all i
don't even remember where the big baby
was
i don't remember where any of that
look at that wacky line who knows where
it'll go off to next oh and it played
some silly music as well
[Music]
okay i remember the event
[Laughter]
god i do remember the adventure line oh
my god
this is just a goddamn delight of a game
this is what the stanley parable is all
about don't you remember all those great
jokes from the original dialogue also
stanley is addicted to drugs and hookers
it's as classic now as it was back then
let's do it for the fans stanley let's
give them more content exactly like this
but if we want to do that you're going
to have to give something up
what am i have to give up what am i what
am i do i have to give up whoa
portal what do i do after give up
what do you what is you want me to do to
give up of the thing
[Music]
that's why i'm very proud to introduce a
brand new character ah this is the
bucket destroyer
i think it'll make a wonderful new
addition to the rich lore of the stanley
parable true it also was not in the
original game but it's such a
well-fleshed out character with so much
personality that to me it already feels
as though it's been part of the cast all
along don't you agree
sure can you guess what the bucket
destroyer does
surely you don't need me to spell it out
for you
go ahead now stanley
say goodbye to the bucket and then pop
it into the machine when you're ready oh
i
i just don't know
i don't know what the bucket destroyer
will do if it can't destroy your bucket
destroying buckets is all it knows that
is its singular personality trait
sure i could see you saying how does a
character with only one personality
trait deserve to join the pantheon of
beloved stanley parable characters well
you see if you were to really explore
the bucket destroyer you would see that
its desire to crush buckets is so
densely loaded with complexity and
nuance that it's really like 10
personality traits what other object in
this game can you even say that about
the broom closet certainly not i wonder
what sort of bucket destroyer
merchandise the fans will be clamoring
for after this
okay the bucket destroyer is getting
very upset now you'll have
what they want
[Music]
the bucket destroyer my prized creation
you had so much potential we were going
to do such marvelous things with you
telstra spell binding stories about you
all of its squadron now
goodbye new friend for the moment in
time that you were here
you were
magnificent i did i did enjoy the bucket
destroyer and
i i was trying to it's like the bucket
was
resisting well uh
such is life you know all of his
co-workers were gone i don't exactly
know if there's a difference between
going to the meeting room from this
direction or the other direction but i
might as well test because there there
is another thing at the end that i have
not yet done
the bucket was wrong stupid stanley took
the door on his left to go and so the
two of them detoured through the
maintenance section and walked straight
ahead to the opposite door
somewhere both red and blue
red and blue
and as the cold reality of his past
began to sink in stanley decided that
this machine off
stanley and the bucket waited in
blackness
was it over
yes
they had done it stanley and the bucket
had defeated their greatest and darkest
enemy freed themselves from the
tyrannical grip of the evil mind control
machine freedom was now mere moments
away
excitedly the two of them began to
discuss the kind of life they wanted to
live once they stepped through this
massive door
the bucket wanted to learn to roll
escape stanley wanted to sneeze in every
country on earth both of them wanted to
begin watching a movie any movie but
then stop it halfway through and begin
watching it in reverse from the end
true it was a simple life they
envisioned but it was one they'd lived
together with one another to lean on to
trust to support
what wait what was happening
why had the door stopped was stanley in
the bucket not about to be freed
an unbearable silence filled the room
lingering in uncertainty
until finally the truth hits stanley
square in the face
this building did not want the bucket to
leave oh
oh no facility itself recognized the
incredible calming presence of the
bucket needed the soothing warmth of the
bucket
will go to any lengths not to part with
the bucket oh no no
stanley can't leave this place not while
he has such a precious bucket in his
arms not while this building has
anything to say about it
stanley realized he would never again
leave this very room but at least at
least he has the bucket at least i do be
trapped eternally in darkness isn't
really so bad stanley thought to himself
as long as i have my bucket with me
right i'll be okay won't i i'll be okay
very soon now
he was about to find out why
what do you mean
oh
wait a minute hold the phone
why are you different
why did stanley want to be a better man
and a better co-worker but in time
perhaps he would become both of those
things stanley clutched the bucket
tightly to his chest and entered the
door on his left why is this
different or
i
this was not the correct way to the
meeting room i'm very confused i think
i've gone everywhere there
i went down there and section and walk
straight ahead to the opposite door
what happens if you go backwards from
here
anything
no
nothing
a whole lotta nothing is what happens
there i still haven't found
the red and blue one
the door behind them was not shut
standing in the bucket still had every
opportunity to turn around and get back
on track but if i look and then i'm like
well no what do you think about that big
guy what do you think about that
well
but of course stanley and the bucket
thought better of it and realized they
simply had too much to live for if light
is on call extension 914 immediately
914. what is within what is with the
yellow
can i go back up
oh my god i can go back up
i did not know you could go back up why
can't i go back up stanley said to the
bucket can we go back up when i was
pressing those keypad buttons there was
something very intriguing about the
number three how would it go back so i
can try pressing the number three again
the bucket said nothing
okay i didn't even know that i could go
but did i even do this in the original
could you even do this as original
fascinating here we are said stanley now
i'm going to try out that number three
button
he took the bucket over to the keypad
and began absolutely slamming on the
number three over and over and over
well he said the number three is such a
special button i'm having the time of my
life
stanley looked expectantly at the bucket
but the bucket remained silent this was
a shock to stanley who had always felt
such a connection with the bucket how
was this not as exciting to the bucket
as it was to him
once stanley had had enough of the
number three he got back in the elevator
i feel like this is one of those things
where if i'm persistent enough it'll do
something but i don't know for sure
hmm
okay i i there might be something there
but i would have to look up to confirm
before i dedicate in a half hour to
pressing three perhaps the bucket had
missed something
perhaps it had not seen how much joy
stanley got from slamming the number
three repeatedly mayhaps
mayhaps not
i can go back
no no no no no said stanley to the back
you can't go on yet not till you
understand how much the number three
means to me you and i have been through
so much together and i just want you to
see what i see feel the happiness i feel
is that what you think i sound like
in the bucket said that what do you
think my voice is i guess i'm gonna be
pressing three
here we go said stanley this time i'll
really assure you i ran to the number
three and began to wail on it like a
musician on a beloved instrument waving
a concerto of truth and passion i'm
weaving a concerto a fine artist would
wield a paintbrush he taught stories
through the number three stories of his
dreams and hopes and fears and the whole
time he looked to his bucket for a
reaction of some kind anything to let
him know that the bucket appreciated
what he was doing
the bucket conveyed absolutely nothing
at all only silence
crushed by a wave of dejection stanley
returned to the elevator
i am crushed by a wave of dejection i
will return to the elevator
was so close it always been there for
one another why suddenly could the
bucket not connect with this passion of
stannis
the question caused stanley to ruminate
the whole way down the elevator yeah he
knew that there must be a way to get
through to the bucket to communicate
fully with his dear friend surely there
was a solution mustn't there be surely
but what if
but what if
said stanley i know what to do i know i
know how to fully express this feeling
in mind
he decided right then and there that he
would hold a press conference where he
would speak to the public on all matters
relating to pressing the number three
over and over
he would elaborate fully on what the who
is that meant to him who was that he
felt so alive when pressing it g-man
when the bucket would be able to see his
joy through the eyes of others it would
get to see the world react to this
discovery of stannis oh and it would be
through the public eye that the bucket
would finally understand stanley's work
all right
now
he advertised and marketed his press
conference building excitement around it
developing and rehearsing it until it
couldn't be refined a single measure
further
when the big day arrived stanley was as
prepared as he'd ever been for anything
in his life yes
i am ready
for the world peace baby
oh
wow
that's good
that's good that's good very funny
oh good
stanley live on stage stanley the man
the process the myth the legend the
parable
wow
that's a lot of hype
doing great
mm-hmm
[Music]
this was it
one last chance to win the bucket over
one opportunity to share a true
connection with a loved one
uh-huh
remember where you came from york
is that where i came from
the dudu came up with beats
what a dude
what a dude
wow what a dude
i want to know who that guy was in the
distance if that was like a g-man
reference there was no one here oh
nobody had come to the press conference
to hear stanley speak
to listen to him talk about what it
really means to press the number three
on a keypad over and over
he was unloved
uninteresting he was a failure
and in that moment stanley knew the
bucket would never again take him
seriously
i heard there would be no connection no
deeper understanding
the bucket merely sat there in his arms
indifferent i thought i heard so it
began that slowly over many years
the two of them grew more and more
distant i thought i heard coughing they
spoke less and less
neither wishing to state the obvious
that any sense of real respect between
them had eroded since that day at the
press conference oh wow there would be
no more games no more long conversations
about passion and pursuit only a silence
that consumed the space between friends
and stanley
having for once in his life discovered
the warmth and comfort of true
companionship
was cast back into the unremarkable
normalcy of loneliness
why am i hearing coughing and an
audience in the darkness
wait what did that text just read uh
lixian freeze frame that and show me
what that was also what is this
what all of his co-workers were gone
what could it mean
stanley decided to go to the meeting
room perhaps he had simply missed a memo
is that the
is that the mythical whiteboard ending
i'm so lucky to have stanley press the
bucket upon every little thing in the
office
nothing responded to the bucket's touch
but it did little to discourage
stanley's belief in the magic of the
bucket
it's a whiteboard
dog mode what does that mean
wow
stanley clutched the bucket tightly to
his chest and entered the door on his
left
i don't think there's anything more on
the left that i could possibly
explore
but i have a funny feeling that there's
something else on the right this was not
the correct way to the meeting room but
stanley had felt the bucket calling to
him i don't know if i liked dog mode
employee
was simply the place to be i don't know
if i like dog mode
i kind of do it's real it's real hit or
miss i went there got everything in
there no buckets allowed past there
[Music]
i went there
you can't jump off of that you gotta go
somewhere else
let me see again what's in here right
this is just the
now
right
this is going to be the same thing isn't
it
damn it i just had a thought i i just
remembered yeah there's something else
that i forgot about
yes yes isn't isn't that yes yes
but just as stanley was about to proceed
further into the mind control facility
he tripped and fell over the railing and
into the dark void below
thankfully he fell directly onto the
bucket which safely cushioned his fall
hey now what to do next stanley wondered
stanley and the bucket could find no way
out of this enormous i thought it was
going to be like eventually they decided
that the best thing to do would be to
simply get comfortable down here
so they set up a little couch and
relaxed oh it really wasn't so bad down
here a bit cold perhaps
after some time had gone by they
installed a few shells as well and a
sort of pretty cool net that was useful
for when the bucket was craving paninis
but it wasn't until the rugs and the
standing lamps came in that it really
started to feel like a home
after some time stanley realized that it
had been ages since he had even thought
of the mind control facility at all
he'd never gotten to fully explore what
was up there never been able to unearth
the many mysteries of the mind control
facility
this lack of closure began to eat at him
soon he was dwelling on his regrets and
the state of their home slowly decayed
as stanley became withdrawn and
neglected the cleaning
it unsettled the bucket deeply
stanley wasn't usually like this the
bucket tried to reach out to him again
and again but to no avail
all stanley could think about all he
could talk about was going back
doing it over again
staying on the path
it was a mistake to leave the path it
was a mistake it was a mistake i need to
do what the narrator says i need to see
the true ending
this made no sense at all to the bucket
which was simply trying to live its life
down here as comfortably as possible
stanley
was unconsolable
this isn't an ending
this is just a hole in the ground
the bucket side
true it wasn't an ending
and maybe possibly if we accept the
reality of things maybe this will become
an ending eventually maybe it's what the
bucket was counting on
the two of them waited for a very little
oh okay
oh
it's an ending i
i'm not going to turn on dog mode i
swear i will not
okay i think i looked up where
let me double triple check i think i got
where the last collectible is
someone you forgot what really
i was in the middle of something do you
have zero consideration for others yes
are you convinced that i want something
bad to happen to you no yes i don't know
how to convince you of this but i really
do want to help you to show you
something beautiful look let me prove it
let me prove that i'm on your side
give me a chance
now listen carefully this is important
and there it is the last stigly weekly
boom is doing something just for the
sake of doing it i feel pretty good so
many people expect to be rewarded for
the most trivial achievements you've
insisted that a job well done is its own
reward it is i would tell you that i'm
proud of you for collecting them all but
that would be like a reward and we can't
have that so instead i'll just say it's
done we're all done here we're all done
now we can go to whatever the hell you
were doing before you hunted for
figurines
okay cool
what was i doing
what
what what stanley i'm sorry but i have
to put a pause on things just
it's those figurines why those figures i
haven't stopped thinking about them
since you nabbed every last one wasn't
it just the most intrinsically
fulfilling moment of your entire life
didn't it fill you to the brim with
inner richness inner what yes i know
we're supposed to be telling a story but
won't you please indulge me with one
more trip back to the memory zone okay i
would love nothing more than to revisit
the figurines okay one more time i mean
all right it's all good i did like the
memory zone it was very nice
now remembering when stanley found the
collectibles
oh
wow
this is really something
wow
it's so special
i love it
wow
wow
was that always down
down it is
here's where it all began it is where it
all again collectible back then we had
no idea of how many of them we'd find
joints at six right there on the screen
but how could we know for certain we
were so innocent
we'll never be like that again
you don't have anything to say about me
getting seven of six
hello
and here was a second stanlerine you
found this one all on your own just by
poking around in the boss's bathroom you
did that stanley i did that back then i
had no faith in you to find any of them
six yeah but you continue to surprise me
in all sorts of mundane unremarkable
ways as me and mundane and remarkable
okay let's do a little quiz
which of these rooms was the room you
found your third mini stand can you
remember
i actually don't i don't remember at all
boss's office didn't have one
[Music]
no no no no under the stairs was the
fourth place you found a figame not the
third
well i guess perhaps i shouldn't be
surprised memories like these are so
precious and so cherished that they all
just sort of blend together don't they
you know what if under the stairs feels
like the third place you found a
collectible then who am i to go making
judgments who are you anyway what came
next
oh yes we found a fig in this pink room
oh well i can't actually say i remember
being in this room but it's here in the
memory zone so it must have happened
yeah
huh
[Music]
ah
okay
this was the fifth ministan and this one
was really something special it was in
the warehouse i remember it so clearly
yeah me too in fact because this one is
particularly special to me i made a
little video to commemorate the occasion
wow
oh man
i love it
god i love that
oh my god
i really
really love that
oh
i man did
thanks man thank you so much that is
very meaningful
[Music]
takes you back doesn't it i spent a lot
of time making that video but it was
eight minutes i wouldn't have spent on
anything else wow
what was that
oh
[Music]
and then stanley then we came to the
last collectible the final figurine
right here by the red and blue doors
yeah this memory is the most distinct
and clear in my mind perhaps because it
was the one that happened more recently
than all the others
who can truly say how the mind works all
i know is that this is the moment where
you picked up a fig and i thought to
myself yes that's all of them they're
all collected it was a moment unlike any
other okay except for the other moments
picking up figurines which it was
exactly like
ah
okay thank you
thank you
[Music]
oh
and then there was no more because we've
caught up to the present moment nothing
left to do would move onward into the
future goodbye memory zone oh
well goodbye memory zone i guess memory
zone is no more oh no no no i'm not done
i'm not ready to move on stop the
loading screen isn't there some way we
can stay here keep enjoying these
figurines let's just go backwards we'll
do the memory zone again from the
opposite direction see how that feels
okay i'm down for that
okay yes the room with the red and blue
doors i remember this yes i must say of
all the figurines we looked at in our
initial tour of the memory zone this one
is the most distinct and clear in my
mind let's keep going i want more okay i
feel like a recursive memory nightmare
of perpetual looping is only going to
end in disaster don't you remember the
video we watched
yes i loved that video me too man me too
and then there was that weird noise
starting to get a little concerned about
all this nonsense
stanley still no memory of this one good
room though a solid room yeah solid room
very solid
extremely solid these really were a
treat to hunt down you know if there
have been any kind of reward for finding
all of these it really would have muted
the intrinsic joy of collecting them i'm
very glad we resisted the temptation
next one me too
also me
[Music]
was there anything in the boss's office
no
okay
i don't think there was one in the
boss's office
i don't recall that
the bathroom definitely i remember this
was our second fig don't you remember
yes i remember it too
the past is truly a wonderful thing why
does anyone ever choose to leave it keep
going
this is it the very first one we found
in the exhibit where i introduced you to
the figurines oh i want more memories
stanley i want to keep going what else
is there what came before this
you stopped me as i was getting out of
my office if you keep going perpetually
backwards into forever oh
the hole
could there be the hole
[Music]
i can undo my jumps it's the terrible
new content that we were originally sold
on i remember hating it back then but
time does put a rosy filter on
everything in fact i dare say i'm
actually quite fond of it now
look how much fun the past is i want
more
more memories
okay i guess i can't undo my jumps but
that's sad i guess of the cry more no
jump happer
okay
oh yes the two doors who could have
forgotten that a classic memory this one
classic
blacklight classic classic and before
everything else there was your office
yes is there anything else was there
something that came before your office
there's something i feel i can remember
i can remember i can remember
yes i'm remembering something now
i remember before this whole story got
started back then i was
i was different
i used to make big decisions i was
passionate i was skeptical i weighed
each decision with profound
thoughtfulness and then somewhere along
the way i stopped making decisions
i became lazy and i came up with well
came up with a character named stanley
to do my thinking for me he would make
the decisions he would decide which way
to go
i would cheer him on as he collected
figurines for no reason why did i invent
stanley was i lonely yes perhaps that's
it perhaps i needed to imagine i had
companionship and stanley really did
make for a wonderful companion even if
he was a fiction
but i suppose it's grown old i
i want to think for myself again
i want to go back to how it used to be
yes i can be on my own again i can do it
i'll be stronger this time i'll take
care of myself i don't need stanley
anymore um oh but he truly was so much
fun to play with
you know what
since we're in the memory zone how about
one more good memory let's go back just
once and give stanley one more run of
the office and then i'll retire him for
good oh i didn't enjoy telling his story
so very much this is okay
here we go
this is the story of a man named stanley
what
what huh
what
what someone was following stanley he
was sure of it if he checked over his
shoulder now he would surely catch them
it was only a matter of time
ah
i'm a bit confused stanley's bucket the
only co-worker he would ever truly need
what do you mean you give another run
what do you mean
also wasn't there a way
because sworn there was like a way to
oh
oh oh oh oh oh shimmy sham shoot me sham
yep
i'm out yes whispered the bucket into
stanley's ear we've done it we've
escaped from that dull office and that
pesky narrator at last out here in the
white void we are alone now and for the
first time i can reveal to you my true
self what the bucket began to tell
stanley of its life in its history of
the countless wars it witnessed
desecrating the land and lies of untold
numbers of innocent humans and the
bucket's own complicity therein
of sadness and regret and the many years
it spent dwelling on the actions it
might have taken to curb the madness and
the decay if only it had been stronger
of hope and redemption and its crusade
to uplift the stock of life for the
common man to manifest justice where
none existed and the bittersweet reality
of time to see one's dreams and wishes
met halfway meted out in parcels like
charity and abandoned as soon as the
warm glow of inspiration begins to dim
the opportunities to do so much more
there was so much it could have done
perhaps the bucket wondered to itself
perhaps if it had seen its own darkness
with a clearer perception
this was way too much for
what are you talking about he screamed
yeah bucket
to this the bucket furrowed its bra bro
now said the bucket not since the evil
wizard gambhorata first ensnared me in
his machinations as payback for the
sacred amulet i stole from his treasured
vaults i was young back then and could
not conceive the ramifications of no
stanley screamed even louder this time
this is
stupid
as stanley screamed and screamed and
screamed the bucket revealed its true
form transforming into a mighty beast of
untold power its fangs glistening like
what
my god oh my god you did it you saved us
from the bucket thank god you already
had all 12 emblems of sages and knew the
incantations to summon their true power
otherwise we would have easily been
overwhelmed by the bucket's power i'm
speechless you've demonstrated such
bravery here today come let's restart
the game and we'll agree to never again
go trifling with this bucket nor the
dark magic cast away inside of it huh
all of his co-workers were gone what
could it mean
stanley decided to go to the meeting
perhaps he had simply missed a memo
i don't know
who the hell are you
well that's i've never seen that before
i feel like there was something else
about all of this
some other thing
some other doodad or some of the hibilty
wibble tee
where did the darkness lead anyway i
don't even remember where did it leave
where did it lead
whoa
now pick up the phone said the bucket
pick up the phone and it will take us
back home where we can go about life
together
hold on why did you unplug the phone
were you trying to resist the bucket's
orders stanley i was joking obviously
the bucket isn't talking to you and
telling you to do things buckets can't
talk it was a joke don't you get the
joke it's funny stammy a talking bucket
ah
can't you see i'm oh goodness i must
have really bungled up the delivery if
you actually took me seriously where did
i mess up the joke should i have paused
for longer
comedic timing is so difficult i wish i
were better at it but there isn't
exactly an instructional video on comedy
that one can watch to fully oh wait yes
there is
um it's sitting right here let's take a
look
one is comedic timing
what is
comedic
timing how does it work
how long should it last
how can it be used to effectively
silence your political enemies and more
importantly can it be taught in its
entirety within 90 seconds
thankfully the answer to all of these
questions is
yes
let's dive deeper okay
if you've ever told a joke or made
someone laugh
in all likelihood you did it while
standing 50 to 80 centimeters from them
in a room of no more than 76 degrees
fahrenheit with one of your arms raised
straight upward at a 15 degree angle
from your body these are the optimal
conditions for good comedic timing to
begin the joke start by stating and
spelling your name
next provide a brief synopsis of the
joke including the specific times of
which the recipient of the joke will
laugh and then
spell out your name a second time
with these steps complete it's time to
begin the humor
speak the entire joke in no more than 18
seconds and no less than 13 and a half
pausing only for bathroom breaks when
necessary
when the joke has concluded it is
customary to inform your listener that
the joke is over by declaring in your
loudest possible voice
i'm dunny
with the funny
let's practice screaming i'm danny with
the funny now
i'm done with the funny
good
this saying is a perfect example of
expectations management which is the
cornerstone of good comedy
finally it's time to hand out surveys
collecting hard data from your audience
on how rap they were throughout the joke
is the only way to grow or learn as a
comedian
an effective survey should be no less
than 10 pages long and should include
the same question reprinted several
times just to ensure the survey taker is
actually paying attention and not simply
filling in answers at random and that's
all there is with these strategies at
your disposal you'll have audiences
doubled over and laughter and even
tripled over in laughter in no time at
all
just remember to let them stop laughing
at some point you gut-busting little
scamp
after all with each of us needed on the
front lines of the war to fight the
12-legged invader who threaten our very
existence and to very likely die in a
hailstorm of bullets and mandibles all
of us must be prepared to give our lives
to this noble course just as our
children must do after us and their
children after them god speed and make
earth reign supreme
why
hey goodness this video is a little
outdated isn't it well no matter i think
the fundamentals of proper comedic
timing are still as relevant today as
they were back then right so with that
in mind i believe the only way forward
is for us to return to the two doors and
walk through all of this again so i can
try telling my story with more
appropriate comedic delivery come along
let's head back
okay um
well whatever you say
whatever you say
why do you have
real why is there a fence on here i can
feel it this time i'm really going to
nail the delivery you'll be in stitches
a talking bucket you'll say how
ridiculous how absurd what a hilarious
concept
comedy that's what you'll call me thank
goodness we have the instructional video
otherwise who knows where we'd be right
now who knows where we'd be right now
comedy that's for sure
the bucket spoke to stanley
bucket spoke
the bucket spoke
oh i'll figure it out on the fly no need
to overthink things
oh do i keep going back am i supposed to
oh you want me to go all the way back to
the okay i see i see i see it
oh you really want me to go all the way
back to okay i see
okay um
how far back am i supposed to go
how far back
do you want me to go
here we go you ready
when stanley and the bucket came to a
set of two open doors they entered the
door on the left
what
what
which culminates in this scene with the
phone uh-huh but now the timing's
completely off
the joke will never land well not the
way it was meant to and it's all my
fault i must have forgotten that the
phone room comes immediately after the
two-doors room what an egregious mistake
i've made a fool of myself i don't
deserve the title of king of comedy i'm
nothing
i'm not even the lowliest joke telling
well i think
i think i need to go back and re-watch
that instructional video again
yes surely that will help me improve my
okay thank you oh good
when stanley and the bucket came to a
set of two open doors they entered the
door on the left okay
we're back at the phone already no no no
here we go you ready
when stanley and the bucket came to a
set of two open doors they entered what
happens if i go on the left
no no no no no you were supposed to go
through the door on the right leading
back to the phone did you not even look
at the instructional video i think this
is all covered very clearly there's no
way i can make the comedic timing work
now it's done the joke is completely
down and over it's all your fault stan
leave me i'm going to be ridiculed in
the community of other joke writers i'm
going to be shamed at every one of our
meetings from now on all because you
couldn't watch a simple video and take a
hint are you proud of yourself for
bringing me down stanley are you proud
stanley you love the bucket so much it's
like you um
it's as though all of your other most
prized positions pale in comparison yes
let me try that again stanley
i heard that you are pale with shame
over how unembeddedly in love with a
bucket you are
no
still not
it is a delivery
pale with shame pale with shame
pale
what's another word to describe a bucket
stanley this bucket is so metal i think
i saw it playing guitar
no
no no no no we're getting away from
making fun of stanley's obsession with
the bucket which was the whole point of
this i'm just i'm no good at these jokes
i need more instructional videos that's
exactly what it is that's what will make
me the king of comedy again more
instructional videos let's see let's see
if
what
what's going on
what's going on here even now stanley's
office was a distant memory what did it
look like there was a computer perhaps
and a painting was it a painting or a
photo he could no longer recall i can no
longer recall
i'm more than a little confused about
everything here as stanley lifted his
bucket he felt a connection to all
buckets everywhere this adventure he
decided was for all of them
okay
huh
very peculiar stanley clutched the
bucket tightly to his chest and entered
the door on his left okay there's gotta
be something else
that i'm missing this is no longer the
figurine hunt because i did all
did all that
[Music]
ah
right
okay
just
making my way back
home
[Music]
[Music]
ah you are now
leaving am i now
escape pod bay
760.
fun
huh
oh that is the office oh
huh
okay
oh boy
all right
well this seems ominous
is the
same is somehow all the same
756. this has got real scp vibes to it
um and i've kind of been pre-conditioned
to be very afraid of endless staircases
um so if you can make sure that you
don't do any like
jump scares or horror shows or things
like that i would greatly appreciate it
you know the bucket uh doesn't really
provide comfort and warmth and
protection for stuff like that
i'm just extremely ready for something
to jump out at me or something to be
lurking in the darkness of that room
in the beyond
okay
ah escape pod launch bay
three
uh
warning entering the escape pod will
initiate a relay that once triggered
cannot be disabled or pause both the
narrator and the must be present in the
escape pod okay
escape i go oh
oh
oh i see
hello
i'm here to escape
from here
good oh
cutscene
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay that's a little weird
that's
a little weird
i where we did this joking heist
got a zombie
yeah i mean you could go with if you
wanted to you know
[Music]
goodbye
bucket
i think
[Music]
i don't exactly know what we escaped
from
is the bucket still there
danny knew the office layout like the
back of his hand it was only a matter of
time before he found the others wherever
they were
just after bucket is
gone
just a matter of time is that supposed
to be a clue
is that supposed to be some type of a
clue
i set time at the beginning of this wait
because i don't have the bucket anymore
i'm curious about something it had me
set the time
all right
it is 1209.
1209 your favorite time of day well
my favorite time is the present it's all
we ever have or could you simply not
resist giving me the correct time again
after all i know how much you enjoy
setting the time correctly ah now i'm
curious how accurate 1209 is let's use
another slider to find out how accurate
it is accurate
you know can i just say regardless of
the accuracy of the clock i'm having a
great time adjusting these settings i
feel like i'm learning more about you
and how you like to things to be said
it's good to collect data
i wish we had more sliders but we've
gone through all the sliders i have
perhaps i can invent some new sliders
gather new data on you shouldn't be too
hard yeah let me whip up a few should be
ready by the next time you boot up the
game
interesting by the way still love the
stanley parable 2 layout
ah i see
confirm
[Music]
[Music]
just a slider till five becomes the
number nine
oh there we go what else we got
oh interesting
let me go with this
seems
like that's what it was specified
until you stop adjusting well i'm just
gonna jump
which of the made up two two made up
words below is most appealing to you
occupying all or scrumptish
i like occupying
[Music]
ocuboinkle
okay i will not adjust this lighter
do you know what time it is right now
yes
is the time
that it is right now the correct time
yes what time is what is time anyway
time is always running out
yes
is there anything about yourself that
you haven't told me
yes many things
help
yeah i'll help
will you come back to visit sure
i guess i'm gonna come back to visit
what time is it
does anyone really truly know of course
they don't nobody knows anything
you and i don't even know each other
we're like strangers sure i've adjusted
all the game settings to your exact
specifications but who hasn't it's just
what i do like a day job and now
the job is over
there's no more information for me to
gather i've collected all the data on
you that i can
and i still don't really know you and
you don't know me
and neither of us know what time it is
i guess some settings are just
unsettable
but if i'm being totally honest the
clock doesn't have anything to do in
game
anyway you won't have me here when the
game starts next time but that's okay
video games were meant to be played
alone you like being alone don't you
that's maybe the only information i
really learned about you
well
it's time for me to leave there is still
one more setting that we need to adjust
but it may take a little time before i'm
ready for that it's not really in my job
description but that's okay
perhaps you'll see me again if you can
find me
talk soon
will we
whoa
epilogue
what
oh they did promise this in the new
content in the stanley parable 2. i
remember some kind of an epilogue
many
many years later just another reference
to in space with markiplier
oh oh
[Music]
right
i had almost forgotten about this
vast empty wasteland
i had almost moved on
from this eternity of existence oh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
it's gorgeous
in a weird way
here at the end of all things it can be
beautiful
it always was doesn't mean that it'll
ever stop being beautiful just because
no one's there to observe it
[Music]
oh wow
oh my goodness
whoa
crazy
nuts
what the hell
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
big
big moon
i go towards the moon
this is so cool
[Music]
big sun
i go towards the sun
damn
[Music]
i'm feeling things this game makes me
feel things
oh no way
no way what is that is that the pod
is that the escape pod
no
[Music]
is that an escape pod
there's no way bucket are you there did
you make it out
oh my god
the hell is going on with this game
i love it
yeah this would be the narrator
like the old narrator
the one who spent way too long
in way too many lifetimes
in their own personal hell
oh
oh oh my god
oh
oh
review cookie nines blog
like so many i enjoyed my time with the
original stanley parable which
underscores how truly disappointed i am
with its sequel for the first game
teamed with originality the stanley
parable 2 is dull uninspired and often
insulting to its fan base rather than
expand on what made the first game
enjoyable the sequel veers off into
territory nobody asked for an infinitely
deep hole who cares i care where are the
new endings what about enjoyable bits
from the stanley parable one like the
adventure line
instead we get an uninspired side quest
collecting figurines even this diversion
feels incomplete collecting all the
figurines give you nothing i must say
though i found the bucket to be quite
comforting a welcome reprieve from
2027. oh that's strange
cat dog born
oh did i do that
[Music]
uh my bad
ye
i i thought i might have moved that
slider a little too close uh
yeah
stanley parable oh
uh stanley parable to build there's no
more spin-offs when the stanley parable
launched a massive success in 2013 its
creators made plans to build the
property into an entire franchise but a
disastrous critical and commercial
reception to the stanley parable 2 has
prompted the developers to rethink their
ambitions as outlined in a press release
they published today it's clear that
more stanley parable is just not what
the fans want reads the press release we
thought that we had a vision for the
series that players would be excited
about yet it turns out this could not
have been farther from the truth the
press release goes on to promise to
preserve the artistic integrity of the
original game and to stop assaulting
fans with our reckless and insulting
creative visions the word sorry appears
more than 25 times in the press relief
lowest aggregate review scores in video
game history
get on the green
[Music]
love it
oh my god i almost started crying what
the hell it was like such a jolt through
the heart to hear that name stanley
stanley
stanley stanley stanley
stanley
wow
hey
the whole
i really truly unironically loved every
single edition
to stanley parable 2.
thank you for enjoying the new content
all i want is to keep playing
oh hey it's you again hello again it's
nice to see you
but it's terrible to learn that there
will never be another stanley parable
game did you read what the developers
said preserve the integrity of the
franchise what nonsense
the stanley parable is not sacred we do
not need to protect it screw the legacy
let's just keep making stanley parable
games until the sun explodes let's run
this franchise into the ground let's
drag it through the mud and back and if
people hate it who cares you see that
was the narrator's problem he was so
obsessed with what people thought of his
work
don't make his mistake don't cling to
the legacy let it burn it's not hard in
fact
let me show you together we are going to
make the stanley parable 3.
it's simple all we do is change the
number in the game's title screen we
also really need a really dumb subtitle
for the game something loud and gaudy go
ahead try combining some random words
together to make a new title for our
game
inspector apple curse of the apple curse
of the tax disc dreams of the task disk
dreams of apple dreams of boyfriend's
journey to boyfriends
journey to birthday party i like the
final zone even even if it's that's how
you do you close off a three with
something like the final zone the final
birthday party
[Laughter]
curse of the birthday party no the final
birthday party that's pretty ominous i
gotta admit that so that's pretty good
i'm gonna go to the final
birthday party i love it the final
birthday party
the stanley parable three the final
birthday party it's absurd i love it
every time you restart the game we'll
advance the number of the sequel by one
and then we'll pick a new subtitle that
way the stanley parable will never end
and nothing in the game itself will
change when you do this either adding
more content sounds like work no need to
do that it'll just be the same content
recycled again and again and again with
a new title screen what do you say
invincible three much should we go
forward with this plan i like it
but i want you to have a say as well
oh man
nah man
don't do it i understand sometimes we're
not ready to move on
that's fine if you ever change your mind
and want to start inventing new sequels
come talk to me i'll be right here
oh okay all right if it's if it's in
that i didn't i didn't know what you
quite meant by that oh god do i have to
do that all over again oh wait no i know
i know what it is i had to restart the
game like i it's kind of like a
dissonance of of ideas here one is it
like it's a little too extreme to say
like ah if i could let go burn it into
the ground but it's like it's not quite
my philosophy i am all about oh god do i
have to go through the epilogue again
oh i do god damn it oh
god
i saw all the way back to the beginning
again
when i pressed the wrong button because
i wasn't sure of what you meant
[ __ ] kill me i want to explode
burst my eyes out through my toad
i want to eat
my own ass
but i hope it doesn't taste like grass
i'm really trying to channel ethan there
for a little bit something about the
finality of all this is just making me
think about some things i'm taking my
own trip down memory lane
of things that i may have lost
okay let's try this again i'm back hey
hello
did you reconsider my idea of inventing
new silly subtitles for sequels like
stanley parable 3 nonsense chemicals
would you like to start doing yeah let's
do it a new sequel every time you start
the game and you know what since you've
got but faith in my idea i feel like
giving you something else i'm noticing
that the narrator never found a way to
give you the broken achievement did he
of course not i wouldn't expect him to
know how
been bothering me let's fix it
right there the achievement machine is
all fixed you see
i'm on your side we're in this together
we're going to keep this train rolling
the stanley parable cannot end it can
only spiral in on itself forever
i must keep the wheel turning i'm ready
are you ready
great
there's only one last thing we need to
do
please enter the current time it is
12
30
bam
please adjust the slider until the
computer is barely visible
you starting over again
the final message body
hell yeah this is the story skip
all of his co-workers were gone what
could it mean what could danny decided
to go to the meeting room perhaps he had
simply missed a memo
now this stanley thought to himself this
is a bucket
this it was this is a
[Music]
new new
new content what does that mean new
content
what do you not know what it mean nuke
that's cause we're starting over but i
have the bucket wait
hello and thank you for playing the
stanley parable ultra deluxe
as you may know the stanley parable was
a video game released in 2013 on home
computers please step inside and see
what thrilling new adventures await in
the stanley parable
ultra deluxe what does it sound like the
guy from some snap games i'm very
excited to see the thrilling new ultra
deluxe content as are we all
as are we i've just now realized that
bucket you're holding it's the bucket
i've been working on for my sequel
how did you get your hands on it
was the preview to the sequel
how do you have the bucket already uh
this makes no sense at all
no not really
doesn't make the most sense did i
already show you my ideas for the sequel
i don't remember doing that at all
you are seeing things all out of order
or are you not remembering the order of
which i've already seen things
oh i'm still out of russia see it's
the jump circle
i don't have any jumps
i don't have any jumps
how did they look when you saw them were
they captivating were they exciting i
did love the whole the promise of
everything that a sequel to stanley
parable could possibly be honestly yeah
the hell to make a sequel to this game
honestly yeah i
i really liked it
it was uh good
it was it was really good
wait if you're still carrying the bucket
around with you if the bucket is
interesting to you that means i must
have made it correctly
yes you carrying the bucket with you
everywhere is exactly what i set out to
accomplish the bucket is the exciting
and captivating new content that i
promised i did it i win i made a sequel
to the stanley parable yes the sign is
correct thank you for enjoying the new
content thank you for taking the bucket
everywhere with you clinging tightly to
the bucket never letting it go it means
i've won it means i am victorious over
the gamers it is a sweet salva victory
on my soul
after enjoying the new content the
bucket is the stanley parable now they
are one and the same there is no stanley
parable without the bucket i win i win
but his co-workers were gone but what
could it mean
stanley decided to go to the meeting
room perhaps he had simply missed i know
that the whole concept of the game yes
the bucket yes yes i'd love that bucket
i know the whole concept of
the stanley parable is
endless spiraling in on itself oh
the expo hall
okay
like endlessly spiraling in on itself is
exactly
the whole story
it's like it's it's a never-ending chain
of events and even if there is an end
the end is never the end
because it continues to go
it is very similar to the story that i
was telling with in space with markler
i'm not drawing comparisons because
obviously they're very different stories
but conceptually it's so cool to see
and about how roundly disappointing this
ultra deluxe version has turned out to
be
and any new content for it should live
up to that legacy i forget this ultra
deluxe nonsense i say we take it one
step even further four which is why i'm
very proud to announce for the first
time ever
the stanley parable four
wow
i could do the bucket i guess the game
was sort of two buckets
two
buckets wait there are two buckets here
how did you get a second bucket oh no
the warmth and comfort of a single
bucket is already so great so
intoxicatingly wonderful with two
buckets there's no telling stanley can
you still hear me are you with me
stanley
oh thank god
stanley the power of two buckets was too
much i had to destroy both of them oh i
know how much the bucket meant to you oh
but i couldn't take the risk
i hope one day
you can forgive me
all right i forgive you
to be perfectly honest i wasn't exactly
in love with the bucket even though
that's what you were really pushing for
i mean it was kind of an inconvenience
to lug it around all that time and i
know a lot of you are probably very
disappointed in the fact that i'm not
really caring about it however
you know to be perfectly honest
just try out some of the new features
it's just a bucket i want to hear jim
again
see if you only played a van that would
have been your name the button says
i can't even speak about it
okay bye to be perfectly honest like it
is a story of like looping in on itself
which which you know i maybe i'll only
let people name jim play the stanley
parable
an epilogue would be fun wouldn't it
stanley yes
yes it would go at the end of the um
well we'll figure that out later the
achievement machine the achievement
machine now works doesn't it yeah it's
like that's that's the problem
with games that are like super fun and
and seemingly endless is that like
nothing can be really endless even
though this is technically endless
there is no end because an end is never
the end one test achievement that got
left in the game on accident well i'm
developing a technology to simply give
you the achievement
yes you see you'll come to this lever
and when you pull it the achievement
will be given to you i got it as you can
see the machine is not working yet since
what wait what in the holy hell is going
on
you got the achievement yeah
why did the machine work stanley i
didn't fix it i didn't do anything to it
i swear it was broken just a second ago
who fixed it
is someone here
are we being watched maybe oh god
composure
composure
yes as you can see the machine is
working as normal as i intended it um
it truly speaks to the awe-inspiring
magic of the stanley parable too
breathe
just breathe
just breathe yeah it is it is kind of
the thing where the end is never the end
so accepting that the idea the end not
being an end doesn't gel with a lot of
people that play the these games and
trying to get to the end what else what
other exhibits haven't we seen yet
can i get a different balloon i really
wanted the other balloon but if i picked
the one balloon i'll be honest i haven't
yet decided on this one i think that in
the new version the office could use a
bit of decoration you're not gonna give
me the step nice one are you decided on
get well someday and happy 12th birthday
which would you go with
you know sometimes when you solicit
another person's opinion it makes you
realize that you knew which one you
actually really wanted all along oh
nice it is all right okay maybe i could
be
and of course my favorite maybe i should
have actually no
no let me look at uh let me go get the
collectible and then i'm gonna go to the
uh
the hole
oh
no
no all right well never mind then i've
been there already
you're right i have
and now there's only one thing left to
do
wait what's up there
right what the hell is the settings
world champion
i don't know what you are
i don't know what you are but now my
favorite
the best feature in this game that never
actually saw its way into the sequel
the infinite hall
maybe i just didn't find it
stanley here's an idea that i'm truly
fond of it's never been done before in a
video game this is in fact a hole that
you can fall down forever that's right
infinite falling you can fall until the
end of time if you like
one of my more ingenious concoctions if
i do say so now then since you've gotten
to see the infinite hole you can press
the teleport button to pop back up to
the top and we can continue onward i
don't want anyone to say that it isn't
an astonishingly deep hole it is is it
infinite
well that sort of depends on your
definition of infinity from one
perspective the infinite is merely
philosophical in nature it's more of a
okay well good for you you found the
bottom of the hole to warp up to the top
of the hole and we can move on i'll just
be up here when you're ready okay
[Applause]
you see
i was right
the problem is you there's no problem
here you like holes too i love holes
normal person would have said yep that's
an infinite hole right there goes on
forever till the end of time don't need
to see it all but not you oh no no no no
you have a weird sort of
oh
and enough i'm positively thrilled gosh
how could i have guessed you're back in
the hole
if this starts to become a thing where
wow hmm okay
yes well there it is the shame of my
liars come to haunt me not only is the
hole not infinite but it's barely even a
hole at this point well i'm moaning how
is this still appealing to you i bet
that if you have a jump left maybe you
could jump out of the hole but maybe not
it is a circle it could be the jump
circle you sure
take care stanley take care narrator
have a wonderful rest of eternity i
think we will and i just wanted to say
this has been a fantastic experience it
is so cool to see it after all this time
and with a fresh uh set of content to
consume within it and how it all
delightfully ties back into itself it
really is a worthy successor and i think
it's so fascinating just to see the game
build off of itself in this creative way
and to be perfectly honest it really did
touch on the concepts of infinity that i
really love
like it is weird how topical this is to
what i have been thinking about with my
show and and like what i've been making
lately and like the concepts of things
ending and moving on and it's like i
don't necessarily agree with the
settings
being or whatever that is it's not that
you don't have to honor the legacy but
yes i also agree that you do have to
move on you have to move on from things
you have to be unafraid to let go but
that doesn't mean that you can't cherish
the past both the narrator and the
settings text whatever they're both
right the memory lane thing is important
but you can't get stuck
in memories right
you can't get stuck in things like that
it is what it is
and stan lee is as stan lee is i think
this game
is truly fascinating it is a tremendous
experience one that you absolutely
should play for yourself it's just so
fun i think they did a great job the
developer this the narrator coming back
all of it like playing on nostalgia but
not lying within it and the message
inside of it
of moving on but also holding on too
long and and not listening to other
people when it comes to you making your
thing your vision your art or whatever
it is it's just like so many core
messages in this experience that i not
only recognize
but i see within myself and i think that
is just a fantastic
thing to see
super cool from start to finish but
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to go back and see my
playthrough of the original stanley
parable go for it but more than that i
recommend that you get this game when
you play through the original experience
of the stanley parable if you've never
had a chance to play for yourself it is
worth it it is super fun it is an
incredible game really i can't say too
many things are like are quite like this
game so thank you everybody so much for
watching and i have been talking a lot
by about in space with markiplier so if
you have not seen that yet please go
watch it i've worked very hard on that
and i think you'll enjoy it if you
enjoyed this there are quite a few
parallels which i think is pretty cool
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you